I feel like if we,
if we were allowed to use music,
we're not totally,
but if we would,
I would go with the doors riders on the storm right now.
Two little writers on the stone.
Doon Doon Doom.
Ryan is on the stone
and to really,
okay,
I'll stop.
Tell Dad what the fuck they're not all the big guy.
The Big Guy dropped off the 27 this episode,
this 400th episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by
legal zoom.com if you have anything that you need to get done illegal style,
like what do you want to incorporate and become an LLC,
which is limited legal corporation or some shit.
I don't know what the fuck that actually stands for.
Um,
if you want to get a will,
if you want to even get divorced,
Bam,
you can get divorced on legal zoom.com.
Essentially what it does is it sets up a structure so that you can do things and
things like incorporating yourself or working on copyrights or trademarks and do
it legally without the use of an attorney.
They also will provide you with a contact for an independent attorney if you
need additional guidance.
So if you feel like you're entering into this and I'm like,
maybe I can do this,
and then halfway through you like shit,
they'll help you out so it's not scary,
but you're going to be able to do it.
You know how I know you're going to be able to do it.
Brian did it.
Okay.
I want you to think about that.
Drunk at four in the morning.
I don't even remember not,
that's not to say that Brian might not be going to jail next week for that very
same series of clicks.
It shouldn't be responsible.
He was drinking.
You should be able to sue the alcohol companies for that.
Whichever ones were sponsorable legal zoom should have a breathalyzer.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm.
They what they do is they provide self-help services at your specific direction.
It's pretty simple stuff though.
It's very clear to follow and it can save you all a lot of money and I can also
save you a lot of time and you can do it.
You know in your fucking house,
you don't have to go somewhere.
You can do it it naked.
Nobody can stop you.
Choke is nobody.
Do you understand this?
So if you have an idea for a business that you haven't done anything about,
you can incorporate that shit online.
The online process couldn't be easier.
Go to legal zoom.com enter the code named Rogan.
You'll save yourself some cash.
All right,
you fucks were also brought to you by stamps.com stamps.com is official delivery
system for the desk squad dot t v t shirts.
So if you see those t shirts that Brian has made and designed,
all of those bitches get delivered through stamps.com so we know this is a,
a real legit product.
And what stamped on the calm does,
I should say that clearly stamps.com does.
What they do is they allow you to feel like you're selling shit from your house.
They allow you to do all the weighing and packaging at home.
Then you can print up your own actual postal information.
Joey Diaz,
he talking in the background.
I can hear you well.
You guys are arguing over Duncan.
He distracting him in the middle of the fucking all important commercials.
How dare you,
how dare you.
You're so nice
corporate man.
You can't even help yourself.
You do it almost against your own will.
I don't want to get into government.
The power shut down going on right now.
Time to advertise.
Oh,
that's what I'm saying.
stamps.com is a great way to send out kitty cat tee shirts.
That's my point.
All right.
You don't have to go to the post office and weigh everything out.
Everything that you do it at home,
they provide you with a scale.
If you enter in the code word J,
r e they give you a sweet offer,
no risk trial.
$110 bonus offer includes a digital scale,
enough to $55 free postage.
So go and check it out.
Use the code word J.
R.
E.
N.
Get your hundred and $10 bonus offer.
It's,
we know it works because Brian uses it so much better than going to the post
office and having to weigh all your shit out and talk to people that don't want
to talk to you.
So stamps.com we're also brought to you by onnit.com did I say you have to use a
code word?
Jre Yes.
Yes.
Codeword Jerry for stamps.
Got comp.
Yeah,
you're right folks.
You look what the fuck.
If we want to use these things,
what are you of the same code were you're right.
We've thought about this a million times before.
However,
it's probably never going to happen.
So deal with it.
It's very weird that it's not though.
It's all should be the codeword Rogan yet white.
Mix it up.
I don't know.
People get silly.
I don't understand people.
Brian.
I try.
I don't understand myself though.
What the fuck?
Uh,
anyway,
stamps.com codewords Jerry were also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com
that's o,
n n,
I t.
A.
Use a code name Brogan and you'll save 10% off any and all supplements,
including Alpha brain,
which Joey Diaz is on right now.
He's jacked up for brain smell in the air
and I have some brains.
You do get jacked on that shit at charge up Sam.
Here we go.
We're running out of him.
Especially when he was a Tivo.
And I don't mean this,
it takes you to a different fucking level.
Do those things like crackers.
I can't keep a bottle in the house.
It's gone and I feel bad calling the kid.
No,
no,
no.
Don't feel bad.
We'd love you using it.
We love it.
I feel fucking bad.
I got the daily packages left though.
Those are delicious too.
So
for all the people that call bullshit on anything like the Alpha brain,
just try it the way we have it set up.
It's so easy there's,
or don't try it.
That's cool too.
But if you want to try it,
there's a 90 day 30 pill money back guarantee.
When you buy one of these bottles and one of these bottles of 30 pills,
all you have to do is say this stuff's stocks and you get your money back and I
have to return the product.
No one's telling you anything that's bogus.
All we're trying to sell you is the best supplements that we can find that we
can sell.
Whether it's the best protein power or the best strength and conditioning
equipment.
It's all we're interested in doing.
We just,
I want the stuff that I use.
Um,
I'm a big proponent of kettlebells and all this other shit like battle ropes and
club bells.
They're awesome.
I used them all roomed on it.
Addicted like peanut butter.
I love shrimp.
Shroom tech is a quarter steps mushroom supplement that a,
it gives you more endurance.
It gives you more juice.
It's,
it's with the Chinese Olympic team used.
They found out about it when China started kicking ass and the Olympics and
track and field and you're like,
what the fuck is going on here?
And they found out they were taking this course [inaudible] mushroom and adding
it to their training.
Yeah.
That was when it was first discovered when he's supposed to take it.
Like before you work out.
Yeah.
Take it like an hour before you work out a,
use a code name.
Rogan save 10% off any an all supplements.
And like I said,
we've got a full array of everything from,
from health and fitness supplements to strength and conditioning equipment.
We even sell like blenders,
like we,
so just sell the,
like when I used to make Kale,
Kale shakes and smoothies and those Blendtec blenders,
you can stick an iPhone in it.
We're like,
fuck it.
We'll sell it.
We should tell him it's the shit.
So that's it.
Go to [inaudible] dot com use the code word Rogan and save yourself 10% all
right folks,
this is the 401 this big one,
goddamn miles milestone.
Congratulations.
Show ideas.
Donald Trump,
Brian Redman,
choose music 400
even.
I love Lucy and got 400 fucking
experience.
I'm the episode of,
I love Lucy.
You can sit there for fucking two years and not watch.
I love he has a kid.
They go to Panama,
they meet Superman.
How many fucking,
I love Lucy real quick.
Not to throw you off.
How I only take three shroom texts cause one time I took like five dogs and I
couldn't control myself.
Really.
Like I quit when I started doing the shroom tech.
I would go to the epileptic when I can only do 77
I can only do seven to nine minutes and I would start getting stressed out now
with the,
I got do 45 and that's because I get scared.
I get off,
I hit the bag before I get on the elliptical now for 30 so that's how much,
you know,
I've been working on it for fucking five months.
But the shroom tech I'd take you supposed to take them towards the body weight,
correct?
Yeah.
And I don't even know how to do the math on that,
so I just take three of them just to be safe.
But they're fucking,
I'm telling you man,
I like him.
Yeah,
I talked to you take five.
That's crazy.
It's just a lot of B12.
A lot of be 12 and a lot of quarter steps mushroom and you know,
it's nothing bad for you.
I've never had a bad experience from taking five.
I wouldn't advise people to take five.
I would say cut it off at two three I get gangster with them.
I found all these football players were getting gangster with it.
They take like five Alpha brains and six room texts and I like,
fuck,
these
guys are gigantic.
So I'm like,
I'll try five.
Let's see what fire was like.
But isn't that follow you at that same role that guy told you?
Like don't take too much of,
you know,
like boner pills or something like that?
Well it's,
it's really,
I would say yes,
but it's really,
it's all natural.
It's not,
it's nothing like radicals happening to your body.
It's not a stimulant.
It's not like I wouldn't worry about it.
I wouldn't take more than five.
I know it's happened because of this.
You're going to be watching cnn.com and you're going to hear about some
psychopath wandering into DC with a shotgun and then pictures of Alpha brain are
going to start flashing.
He had 700 bottles back seat of his car.
Please.
He would be enlightened.
You wouldn't be going with a gun.
He would be going with hugs.
It'd be tried to hug him and they shoot him.
That would get,
yeah,
that gets you killed.
Fat Woman.
She was suffering from postpartum and she,
uh,
was driving around.
She was on some sort of medication to travel down on the White House and Scott,
a gunfight with the,
with the Popo.
They wound up killing her.
She had a baby in her car.
I mean,
it's so crazy.
Every time I see stuff like that,
I think,
man,
I wish you could do that in grand theft auto.
It's like you can't,
you can't drive kids around.
If you notice that there's no kids in grand theft auto,
not a single kid.
Why would you want to try a little fake kids around?
But why not?
I want to,
I want it to be realistic.
Drop them off at school,
drive them off cliffs.
Wow.
And killed dogs in it though.
Yeah.
That's where we draw the line.
You can't have fake killing of babies because if you encourage that in any way,
shape or form,
and then it somehow becomes a reality,
like someone decides to make sport of killing babies cause it's a part of a
video game,
it's going to be a real problem.
How fucking crazy as this is happening now,
every three weeks people,
it's pretty crazy.
This is,
this is not even a joke.
No more like it's happening every three weeks and you know what?
It's going to happen around here at a fucking park,
stupid basketball game at the fucking taco place.
There's a lot of issues,
a lot of issue fucking issues.
And I'm sitting there going,
you know,
is this a set up?
There's somebody hanging out outside of fucking psychiatrist's office and when
they see some fucking guy come up and give him a gun and then $20 and say what?
I mean,
what the fuck is going on?
I don't think that,
I don't know what the fuck.
I think it's natural when you have this many people,
it was just natural to go.
No,
I'm not saying that.
I'm saying it's natural.
When you get this many people that are on,
first of all on drugs,
you have a massive amount of people in this country that are on all sorts of
drugs,
whether the,
they need them or not.
Well the reality is the amount of people that are on prescription medication is
very high.
Then you're going to have natural amounts of mental illness.
When you have a high population,
you have higher amounts of mental illness.
They've shown this in rat population density studies.
Apparently I was listening to this podcast about it.
Um,
I think it was psychedelic salon or Mckenna was talking,
I forget it might have been art bell either way.
Um,
they were talking about rat population density studies that they did
the same thing with,
with rats where they started them small and put like a hundred rats in a,
in a,
in a room together or you know,
10 rats or whatever.
And they just kept ramping it up until they were on top of each other.
And when they're on top of each other,
they started exhibiting the same sort of mental illnesses that you see in.
People were like they stand in the corner,
would just shake and rock back and forth.
It couldn't handle it.
He's this,
you started to see all sorts of weird aberrant behavior and they think it's from
the overstimulation cause then when you get to a population density like that,
it's very difficult for the human body to tolerate.
It's very difficult for the human body to to,
to,
to deal with the sheer numbers of people that you interact with on a daily
basis.
It's almost completely unnatural for us.
And so the idea is that in these scenarios most of us can keep it together,
but there's going to be a certain amount that have mental illness and coupled
with a certain amount of extra stress that are highly populated,
cities are providing with a certain amount of extra craziness because they're on
prescription medication.
And then just the stress of life period and all of that together being
unemployed,
financial stuff,
boom,
powder keg.
But isn't this stuff happening mostly in the United States?
And other overpopulated countries.
You don't hear about this.
It's a good point.
You do about some the one in Finland where the guy murdered those kids.
That's right.
There was the guy in Finland,
but he's asked him filling or Iceland or Finland.
Finland,
Joel.
The big one was in San Diego and when the kid willing to Mcdonald's.
Yeah,
the kids.
That was the big one.
That's it.
That was the,
you heard about you went home and there was a special eye and report.
They were in San Diego and the guy had a shotgun and yeah,
that that was,
you know,
now it seems like you expect it.
It's a daily occurrence now.
Well,
some are worse than others.
It's also,
there's a lot of people out there that feel disenfranchised and this is where a
lot of people out there that they don't,
they don't feel like they can make up a dent in this world unless they do
something really bad.
There's,
there's people out there that feel like to,
to get noticed and to get people to recognize them.
They can do that if they do something really bad.
I think it's a,
I think it's a love famine.
I think people are starving for love.
People in the United States don't express love in a normal way.
It's a really weird thing.
Like if you ever let you know like that,
like you might be around friends or even just talking to your brother or
something and you have this impulse where you want to say,
I love you man.
I love you,
but you don't,
you don't do it.
There's a thing that triggers in you or you feel,
I'm not going to say that.
I don't want to sound weak.
Right.
I,
I think that's what it is.
I think people are just so turned around backwards,
uh,
as to the flow,
the flow of nature,
the flow of life that uh,
they're sort of malfunctioning because of that.
Yeah.
There could be that for sure.
There's also this weird transitionary period the human race is going into,
as we get more and more information on a daily basis from the Internet,
it's more and more obvious that the world we live is fucked.
It's like the system's terrible.
We know that we can operate is as individuals and we can be really friendly with
each other.
You know,
we can,
the people in this room can,
we can party,
we can live together.
We can.
If it was just us on the planet and we were the only people that we interacted
with,
we'd have a great time.
So why is it then when you get massive amounts of people,
all of a sudden there's all this death and this all this fucking fighting and
there's all this chaos and this all this,
you know,
lawsuits and bullshit and what,
what is it?
You know what it is about numbers.
Fucking Kardashians.
You know his dad,
the thing it's,
it's a PR two people can have a life now.
Like even Dunkin,
he did own a business.
Do you know that?
And not even talk to each other.
Yes,
you can live in your home.
You can live in your home.
You don't have to talk to each other.
I'm very insecure way behind like texting once a cure.
I want to hear you.
Oh,
you want to know a person's voice?
Hey,
well known tech.
And you don't want even voicemail messages either because you want to
communicate.
I'm old school because I don't want to ever lose that.
I don't know.
I don't know how to say the word would disenfranchising ourselves from myself
and that some people can handle it and some people can't.
I can't handle it.
You know,
I was fucking 30 when I was 20 so I'm an old soul.
I like it.
I liked the contact to me,
I need to hear your voice.
One of the all time,
best douchebag,
acthar stories.
I'm at a restaurant once and this douchebag actors there and he's by himself
eating and he's,
I think he's crazy and he starts talking to a couple that's near them.
Like they're sitting by themselves on a date and you know,
he's fairly famous.
So he starts talking to them like,
how long have you two been together?
You know,
and they're,
they're,
you know,
they don't know what to do,
but they kind of recognize them.
So it's kind of weird.
So they kind of are stuck in this thing where they have to talk to the guy.
And then I'm watching this play out and he's,
he's talking to him.
He tells the woman that she's an old soul.
Jesus.
He told her she was at a,
you're,
you seem like an old soul.
You really seem like an old soul.
You guys really,
I sent something with you too.
Like this is an amazing relationship,
isn't it?
It was so fucking strange and I was like,
get me out of this town.
Get me Outta here.
You people with your fucking emotional support dogs.
I told you about that shit.
No restaurant bigger than me.
Got on a plane with a French poodle.
I was cracked.
Right?
485 with a fucking French poodle guide.
I'm sorry,
just don't even get me started on that fucking issue.
La Has.
People have figured out that there's a work around to this.
Americans with disabilities act and you can say that your dog provides you with
emotional support and you can be like a regular person and you can go into a
restaurant,
a fucking Labrador
seed.
This is a thing.
This is the thing I got to confess when I was with Natasha,
we would,
we realize this trick that you can put a red vest on the dog with a little cross
on it.
You can order them on the Internet and legally people can't ask you what your
disability is.
So it's like,
cause when you know,
when you see somebody with a Chihuahua,
it might cross your mind to think,
how's this thing gonna help them?
If they start having a seizure,
like what's,
what is it?
What's it really going to do is it's going to let you know he's dead.
Bark,
bark,
bark.
So like we,
we started saying that we are doing that and then man got a coat.
I got some emails from people who are disabled and they're like,
you have to understand I have to have this dog.
Like it's trained at until either guide me,
it's trained to like help me if I have a seizure.
And every time you assholes put one of those fake vast on a fucking dog so that
you can go and eat in a nice restaurant with it.
You're making it that more much more difficult for me to do it.
Cause people are getting increasingly suspicious and increasingly suspicious
where they used to not be at all.
So just leave your fucking dog at home.
If you want to go eat pasta,
don't,
don't gum up the gear.
Don't get in the way of people are actually fucking sick.
Yeah cause there aren't.
You can't.
I was one of those cons
in Columbus,
Ohio.
Christina business gain.
Tom's a girl brought their dog using the same thing.
See that shit is so ridiculous.
People with dogs think that just because they love their dogs.
That dirty,
stinky,
open asked animal.
It is not.
Yes it is.
They're rubbing their little asses on chairs and those,
that ass on the chair could have worms in it and the microscopic worms could get
in my hand and I could get worms.
That's real.
It's a dog man.
It's a fucking dog.
It's creepy enough that people drop silverware on the floor and pick it up and
still use it.
Yes.
Like you're going to wipe off with a Napkin.
All the fucking shit eggs that are stuck to the bottom of your shit,
dog.
Shit.
Eggs are clean,
dude.
I love dogs.
You know I do.
I've always had dogs,
but bring dogs to restaurant is a massive douchebag move.
But on a fucking plane or up just as bad on the plane when I was sitting next to
somebody with a fucking dog.
Listen,
I love animals too,
but I don't expect somebody else like them.
I'm old school.
You want to listen to music?
What you fucking me your phones on and I'll put mine in that.
Yeah.
I hope to hear each other's shit.
You might like something different.
So I'm the same way.
I feel like if I was to walk into somebody's space with a dog,
they didn't even know I'd be fucking feeling weird.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
that's just how it was built up.
Like I'm taking,
I'm wasting your fucking time.
And there's people who think they could do that shit on.
Fine.
I know and guide you from emotional support,
but those as a pot Brownie,
you didn't move on a little half of a pop brown.
He going to a restaurant,
you're okay,
you can leave the fucking dog in the car with the air on.
And you know,
some people can't leave the dog anywhere.
They,
them
my cats.
I worry about earthquakes.
[inaudible] gotta if people ate pot brownies,
like you eat pot brownies and went into restaurants,
they would need emotional stuff.
No,
no,
no.
I'm talking about,
I've had conversations with people that do not smoke marijuana.
Then I pilot the brownies and they've given up the little pieces of brownies.
They'll buy like a hundred milligram Brownie on Monday at divine wellness and it
lasts them for days and they drive to Warner brothers and they communicate with
people and they threw away their fucking bills.
Wow.
Okay.
I know.
What pills were they on?
You know the shit that they give you when you go to the doctor and tell him that
you hear voices,
but whatever the fuck they give you,
whatever they give you,
Jo Adderall,
uh,
you know,
I can give you ad or off.
So I'm so,
so sorry guys.
I don't know.
It's not my winner.
What you're saying though,
you know that that's how I meant it.
I didn't mean it was real.
In a funny way.
It's a real tricky to decide what medication is right for anybody.
You know.
I think it's real tricky.
They tried to figure out how another person's mind works and that seems to be
the issue that they have when they're prescribing those medications in the first
place.
Like what our friend was on it.
I think one of the things that came up was that they had a constantly changes
dose.
Absolutely have them different stuff and they,
they will like try this telling me how you feel on this.
Like it's that simple.
I did give you stuff to try and you're like,
wow,
I guess I feel good.
Okay.
It was that you think that's a good dose and you're like,
well,
I feel pretty good.
You know,
everything seems pretty good today.
Yeah.
Like,
okay,
all right,
we're going to keep you at that dose.
And when they start doing shit like that,
it's like,
it's very,
it becomes very subjective.
Like what works?
Why does this one work really good on you?
And that one work really good on him.
I was on Zoloft and I was in college while you on it?
I got depressed.
Wow.
What was God get you depressed?
That's,
you know,
I don't know.
I'm not really sure that I like completely figured it out.
But um,
I dunno.
How long were you on it for?
I was on it for probably six months and I couldn't come.
Like I,
it made it so that I couldn't come anymore.
Like I could,
I could get it,
get it up,
but I couldn't ejaculate.
Awesome.
Couldn't have any orgasms.
It's Brian's favorite new drugs.
I know what's it's called.
So also really bad for your brain.
No Dude.
Especially if you're not supposed to.
Well,
it was,
you know what it did,
what it did was it,
it did produce this,
uh,
feeling the I now associate with when I'm being really healthy,
like when I'm meditating a lot or exercising regularly,
eating right or I want to get all my ducks in a row.
This nice clear tranquility will generally come over things that I'm not,
my mind isn't reactive when any weird shitty thing happens.
It's like you just are sort of at this nice tranquil level.
It kind of kind of reproduce that at the cost of not being able to have orgasms.
And then,
um,
I just stopped taking it and went out in the woods because I was working in the
summer camp.
We're not in there
shot load like a donkey with a cattle prod up his ass
first time coming after.
How long?
God,
I don't know man.
It was a,
it was a while.
I mean,
I could,
it's not like I couldn't come.
It's just like,
it took forever.
Like if you've ever taken a narcotic and tried to jerk off,
it's like that.
It's like it just doesn't happen.
It's like that.
So,
but you can do it if you really apply yourself and work really hard and why you
can like squeeze some juice
after it's over.
Does it feel like you've accomplished something?
Yeah.
It feels like you put your cock and a pencil sharpener.
You been jerking off for an hour straight.
I've had twice at two points in my life.
I have jerked off to the point where I had a blister on my deck.
Oh is it an actual like a blister?
Yeah.
No and like you're like a red spot where I like the more through the skin.
I one of those twice to dry.
Jacqueline.
Yes.
On two separate occasions in my life I did that.
That's how stupid I am.
I the one time beat half time position hijacking a when you're young,
especially when you're young and single,
especially if you're trying to stay single,
like you're trying to be focused in your career.
It was when I was very young.
When you're trying to be focused on your career,
the last thing you want to do is be thinking about sex.
And just for me,
my solution was just beat off on the reg and then it was,
and then it becomes an addiction.
Really?
Yeah.
Should be in the constitution where before politicians make big decisions,
they have to masturbate.
I bet this,
I bet the shutdown wouldn't happen.
Yeah.
Baner and Obama had to jerk off before they decided to do whatever they're going
to do.
There would definitely be less tense or is this still shut down?
It's still shut down.
Yeah,
I got it.
But I don't understand.
You hate emails.
The other day when I went out the end at the workout and on the way home it was
20 to 10 and I saw the Wheatstone like,
oh,
let me go in there.
And on the way home it dawned on me that it's 20 to 10 and the weed store is
still open below I,
the way I word it was the government shutdown and the weeds,
doors we store is still open and will be for the next two hours.
Fucking,
I got hate mail slot you,
you fat.
Fuck.
Why is that bad?
Why would you get a hit?
People were like,
you don't have to stay on what's going on with the government.
This is bad.
This is all because of old guys.
It's a fucking tweaked.
Give him saying what's wrong with you?
This is why it shut down.
Yeah.
Don't get mad at Joey Diaz for stating the obvious.
Can you believe that I have a you.
Cause every time there's a stupid article or something on Twitter and on the
media,
we get fucking Twitter from people across the country like haters.
Hey man,
they're going to shut the fuck and stores down.
What are you going to do then no more.
And all of a sudden these fucking stores of still rocking and rolling.
Denver's rocking and rolling.
I was in Portland last week and those motherfuckers don't know what it is.
Not the smoking.
You know those fuckers savages up there.
They walk around with pat trees and shit and knapsacks and yeah,
I mean that's it.
They didn't have no idea.
So all of a sudden the government shut down because they got no [inaudible],
but these fucking state,
it's got so much gayness and taxes.
I think California is broke,
but at least that generating,
let's look up the fucking numbers.
People,
what's done in the generating,
what's the Denver?
Did you see that 60 minute show
be?
It literally is going to turn the economy around.
This is completely clink,
clink,
clank,
and these dummies,
these,
by the way,
who are the same dummies who are anti drugs.
It's almost like secretly they want drugs to be legal and the only way they can
go about it is to have the government completely collapsed so they can't
regulate them anymore.
And then the drugs will take over in the drugs.
We'll let them understand how they fucked up the entire country with their
country egos and then they can then they can apologize with.
It's almost like the only thing that can save them at this point is pot at all.
The ones that are dangerous at all.
The ones that you want an instant change in the economy.
Of course it's not gonna be under corporate control.
You've got to realize that you ready for that because it's going to be under
control.
But anybody who wants to grow pot,
that's the problem.
If you make it legal,
how,
how legal is it going to be?
He's going to be legal to grow like a tomato.
Like I have tomatoes in my yard.
Is it going to be okay if I grew up on in my yard?
Because if that's the case,
it's pretty easy to do man.
Good luck.
We're off to the races.
The hold co economy's going to change.
Why isn't there a time when we'd was totally illegal,
totally illegal and no one even thought about it for the 1930s and no one even,
it wasn't even a thing.
Like if he,
it was just something else.
You smoked.
It was so common and so normal and so used as a textile and a commodity.
Like it was so important to the making of clothes and for all sorts of different
things that they had before they came out with,
um,
the decorticator when they came out with the decorticator,
it led them to be able to process this shit really fucking easy.
And all the difficulties that they had with processing in the past was gone.
One machine completely figured out how to take this hemp and turn it into,
instantly turned it into what you could use for paper building materials.
Henry Ford made his first fucking car.
He had the fenders made out of hemp.
It's,
um,
it's an amazing plant.
It's one of the most durable fucking plants that's ever existed.
It's lightweight.
It's really weird.
It's not like any other plan.
So the idea of making that illegal was so ridiculous because they had to make
the name marijuana.
What they did was Harry,
Harry Anslinger and William Randolph Hearst and Hearst control all these
newspapers.
We also control all this paper.
He controlled all these like he made,
he had forests and these forest would chop down this wood and use it to make
paper.
He was going to have to convert all that to hemp.
Like popular science was saying Hampton new billion dollar crop.
Like they got it in because of the,
the actual,
the applications for like clothing and nylon and fuel.
That's how they got it.
They got it in as a commodity.
They essentially banned and incredible natural commodity.
One of the greatest ones ever so that they can have nylon for like ropes and
shit like that.
So that Wa Hearst didn't have to transfer his a,
his mills over to hemp paper.
Like there's a bunch of weird economic reasons.
It just stuck so good.
The 1930s it's still stuck.
Like we're running around with the fucking Internet,
with cold Syrup and alcohol and fucking antidepressants and everything else.
And to this day,
one of the best plants that's ever existed on this planet for people is illegal.
Illegal.
I mean if there's no,
you don't need any more proof than that,
that we're fucking retarded.
Like you want to talk about backwards assed civilization.
They've got the best plant ever illegal,
then nothing else can fuck with it.
There's nothing else you can eat.
Make houses with make clothes with and that mother illegal,
it's going to be interested in seeing that population growth for the places that
are legal now and seeing if there,
if there's a growth in like music and arts.
Like if it's become like Portland becomes the new Seattle and like just two
years,
it's illegal in Portland.
It is illegal.
It's illegal in Portland.
Portland didn't close or no.
Well you can have,
I,
you're gonna have medical dig.
Dame didn't make it legal statewide.
They only made it legal statewide.
First was Colorado.
Second was,
uh,
shortly after it was Washington state and those are the only two right now that
it's actually illegal in the state.
But we knew the Denver had passed a city law way back in the day when they said
weed was legal.
They who said there,
we're not going to arrest you don't smoke it in public.
The cops,
like they openly stated they weren't going to do this.
We were saying,
we used to talk about that on stage back when would you,
when the comedy works in the early two thousands
yeah.
It's very strange.
It's a really strange,
a strange phenomenon.
And if you look at it not just from the economic perspective of why people
economically might want to ban it,
but also from the uh,
Carla consciousness level because of the state that induces is one of deep
introspection.
And if you consider a capitalism
okay
and the effects of it,
like what you just said and you really explore like,
shit,
do I want to be a,
do I want to be,
do I want to subscribe to this system that has actually thrown people in jail
for growing a thing that used to be like one of the number one substances used?
That's the kind of thoughts that come to your mind when you're high along with a
lot of other stuff.
Like,
man,
I think I'm a fucking asshole.
Did I really just say that to whoever I said that too?
Like I think I'm a fucking asshole.
And the more you start like thinking about stuff like that,
that I,
that produces the paranoid trip everyone's so afraid of,
but if you take that deeper than what you realize it's happening is the plant is
healing your consciousness and it's identifying aspects of yourself that need to
be worked on.
That's what the effect is.
And also if you get super stoned and just getting to a messy room,
you'll start organizing the fucking room.
Generally you'll start cleaning and scrubbing because you're what it's doing to
you on the inside,
which is organizing all these disparate aspects of your personality and forcing
you to at least acknowledge it if not work on it.
And does that kind of balancing agent work with a society based on denial and as
a society based on ignoring the fact that the whole thing functions by
evaporating human beings and stealing their land.
Do you really want a drug that produces that level of understanding in the
bloodstream of the population?
Well you do just,
you don't,
if you're the one at the helm of the fucking meat machine,
if you're the one that's pushing the blades across the land and slashing
everything in front of it,
then you don't.
But if you're everybody else,
of course you do.
Of course you do.
Right?
We're,
we're all better off.
Hi.
It's,
I've never really known what it is to sit on the couch.
You know,
I don't play games.
No,
I don't play video video games.
I know.
I don't even know.
Play a little pool.
Joey.
Deescalate,
play some pool.
I grew up in a fucking blob.
Straight shoot stays the weirdest thing in the mall that we'd always kicked my
ass.
Like it always fucking beat the fuck out of me.
Like when I smoked it in the morning,
like eight in the morning,
it would pattern my day for me.
Like first off,
you're not going to sit here.
Right?
You gotta get the fuck out of the house.
Right.
Okay.
So it made me go out and get like a,
I always love listening to music.
So I used to get those anytime since 1980 I've always had something around my
ears,
whether it was the big disk,
I never had the big ghetto blaster,
but I had the desert desk and then it's got shorter click cassette and then it
became an iPod.
I don't even know the evolution.
I even had the power booster,
but I bought on [inaudible] New York electronic.
Oh,
you know,
you could buy anything.
I used to buy Sony used to make an amp that you plugged into the Walkman and you
plugged your speakers into the fucking amp.
Well that's how much of a savage I was.
I wanted it because when you're going to New York City,
there wasn't those ear buds denim with speakers,
you know?
Yeah.
But I wanted it loud and I'm pleased to go around with ghetto blasters.
You remember that?
He is at the whole neighborhood,
their own music,
but hip hop a habit to the heaven.
They would like walk down the street like holding on a giant ratio,
boom box that it's gotta be one of the Weird radiations loud stereo that you
carry with you and do to bring them everywhere.
Do you remember that?
But let me explain something to you.
Think of the dudes who did it.
It was the same dude.
Sudei whoever.
Pit Bull.
Hmm.
You're right.
The people who had that.
What people who fucking look kind of scary like what they walk in with the don't
look me cause I'm close.
They'll walk into the fucking house with it.
Blasted.
Well,
in some ways it makes life a little bit simpler because you're walking around
with a soundtrack.
You know I had one,
I had a small one.
I remember this.
Yeah.
That's what they used to carry.
That's insane.
Look at that thing,
man.
That looks like something we would plug into the matrix.
This show.
Yeah.
That looks like the podcast equipment.
He's
got like sliding scales on that thing.
Look at that.
You're turning on him.
Huey Lewis and the news full blast.
It sipped a base band.
I think that guy,
no,
he's probably listening.
Nobody ever took it from Kool g rap and get mugged on their fucking stereo.
Like dog does a help.
Please help us find it.
I'm sure someone must have Joey.
People steal everything.
Yeah,
I saw that on fucking believable.
Joey's on the far right.
That's insane.
We were so cute.
Sexy,
lucky seven.
Can you get it?
So just as whole body feels.
The scroll was 44 I was 44 there was Logan lucky seven.
Wow.
That's so crazy.
Look at you dude.
So how old are you in this picture?
1414 God damn Joe.
You cute.
You're cute as a button.
Look at David Ruiz.
Turn around and talking to the microphone.
Can hear this too.
That kid right Joey top on this screen to that kid with the Afro was a very
interesting story.
This guy right here,
because we were,
we were horrible basketball team at Mckinley.
Can you go full screen when he moved in the neighborhood,
does it do,
he could jump.
He was five foot eight but this kid could fucking jump like Julia survey.
So he was Dominican.
His name was Louis Hernandez.
I'm from Jersey and just playing that,
they just cut it short and called him Louie and Nigga.
They said,
fuck it.
We don't care if he's Dominican.
We're not gonna even think about that.
We're just going to,
this is David rule as they call them that to his face to lake Louise and nick.
Did he get pissed?
Fuck you bitch.
And he was a tough kid.
He get mad at you when you come to was like he,
I think he bit slap two or three people.
He did was we used to do acid when we first started smoking weed in the eighth
grade,
we go behind the soccer field and north Bergen and he let us blow smoke into his
afro and see the smoke come out of the [inaudible].
This was the crew.
So I knew all these motherfuckers scroll down to,
all right,
this kid has no,
that kid dad was David Black.
We graduated together and I knew him after the fact that one night he came into
Joan married,
it's like dog,
you gotta call you gotta give me a ride.
If he give me a ride,
I'll give you a rock guy.
We gave him a ride.
He gets out of the corner of New York.
My three minutes later he comes running back bleeding with his head pulled.
I go,
what happened was I went in to rob my sister.
I mean he was serious.
He had coke rocks,
but everybody chunk of his fucking hat.
She caught him on the way out as he was pulling out of the window and she just
took,
he was bleeding.
He robbed
Terrigal
cocaine was
dog at three in the morning.
You asked me for a ride.
I got to do what I gotta do you know what I was thinking?
How crazy.
That's fucking crazy show.
I wish you could do your own.
Stand by me.
Oh
my fucking God.
This is who is this?
Why is this head so small?
When I got this picture,
I know which one.
The Filipino kid.
Now this guy in the left that kids like a zillion and now his family owns a tow
truck company in northern New Jersey and New York City.
If you get told his family is the one that owns it.
I swear to God,
I believe.
Yeah.
This is fucking crazy shit.
I believe.
Yeah,
it's fucking crazy,
man.
Somebody sent me this yesterday while I was eating.
Wow.
And I almost had a fucking heart attack.
I found looking through yearbooks and that's when I was in,
no,
I was smoking dope then.
I was no innocent that I was smoking dope.
I was finger bang and people like I said,
you can still be innocent and fingers,
just me and my mom at the house.
She,
Hey,
I was okay.
I was going crazy.
Then I smoked my first refer when I was 15.
I ganged it from my dad and uh,
I had no idea how strong it was.
And we rolled a joint and me and my friend Josh and this girl that I was dating,
we smoke this shit and we smoked way too much for 15 year olds,
whatever we were.
And we wound up waking up in various parts of the house like blank,
like blink.
It's never happened to me before,
but like blank,
all of a sudden I'd be on the couch,
blink,
all of a sudden I'd be in front of the frigerator like blink all the time in
between the blanks missing,
just arriving places like waking up in a bedroom with short term memory,
not just no short term memory.
It's like my tape gets cut like the,
the,
the events between those two did not exist.
I get so high,
I had zero memory so I would,
what I would think it was,
it was,
I got so high that I would say,
you know what,
I need to just get into the kitchen and maybe get something to eat and maybe
it'll calm this down.
So my brain spools up that it's got to figure out to remember to get to the
kitchen to eat.
Cause I'm that high.
And then in between,
during the walking,
I forget everything.
So then boom,
all of a sudden I wake up and I'm in front of the fridge ready to go,
what the fuck.
And she was doing it to my girlfriend at the time and my friend was doing it.
My friend Josh was doing it too.
We were all fucking,
it was,
it scared me off a weed for a long time.
Scared me off of weed for a long time.
I didn't smoke weed again for several years.
After that.
The first time you get high,
you really don't get that design.
It's the second or third time and then you like you're outside.
You really start to understand that you ended up at a bowling alley by the
chocolate milk.
That's why I went and ate.
We had French fries and chocolate milk.
Have you ever had that happen where you felt like you woke up and replaces the
third?
I remember the first two or three years I just smoked,
you know,
like don't get it.
What are you doing on Friday night?
Nothing.
My Mom's leaving.
Perfect.
I'm going to call.
Joe will come home with some weed on it home,
Bro.
My brother found that last time.
He's going to rat me out.
Oh,
I fucking will smoke a new yard and we'll going and listen to pink Floyd the
wall.
I mean that's not,
even though the wall wasn't even out yet,
we listened to the Beatles sergeant pepper,
like that's it.
Like we get together and roll a joint.
In those days.
I used to have a glass,
you went to East West,
his headshot and there was a tube and the head was like a flute with this open,
but it had a hole and you put the joint in there and you put your finger at the
end.
Joe Laid it and you'd like to join and I'd suck it in and I'd hold it back and
then it was like,
that's it.
That was your carburetor.
When you smoke one of those,
you got disarmed,
you address it.
And then we'd sit around and we'd all have money,
you know,
like what do you want to do?
How much you got to a quarter,
what do you got?
Three daughters,
I got four.
Let's go to the next.
And you walk to the pizza place member and you know,
you just talked stupidity.
You.
Can you look at each other?
Do I look,
I know you think Nicco say I'm high now.
He's on my,
come on by look.
I know,
but if I seen it was a fucking,
it was tremendous.
They gotta get in the House and walk past your mother and I was sounding like
your mother decided to make cookies so I had to look and talk to her or
whatever.
That's why you smoke pot dog,
because it brought something different to your life at 13 it made you feel
fucking alive.
How cool was it?
Like I always want to do right now,
forget about anything.
I would love to get 60 people and chairs and couches and just fucking come out
onstage and give everybody a joint and the table in the middle with joints and
just do time to all those joints of gun.
Well,
you know there's a couple of places.
That's it.
They're going to start having those in Denver any day.
The only problem is it's against health code to be able to be smoking in a
public place.
We just want to crack jokes dog and bring it back to when you were 14 and you
all sat around and listened to his or something might said or that one arm with
the,
with the White House,
you know,
we had great outcomes and I was growing up,
bicentennial,
nigger,
all those times were brilliant and you'd sit around and with six of your buddies
and listen to George Carlin or Red Fox.
Come on.
You know,
that's what toilets,
that's what hooked us.
That was it.
Just that feeling of listen to this with this motherfucker's saying,
listen to his language.
We don't know anybody who talks like that.
Even George Carlin,
he was so fucking head.
I'm still listening to Lenny Bruce and like being like eight and like turning it
off,
like fucking hyping the goal.
That's what was the first time stand up.
You got to expose to Richard Pryor.
That Nigga is crazy.
Why?
No meat to Dracula pushed me over the fucking top rule and crying like,
Mommy,
I got to tell you this joke.
And then putting it on and going back and tell him,
and y'all don't admit the curses you,
I don't meant the curses.
And then you learned,
you know,
and all that age,
I wasn't into fucking the black dude.
Everybody supposed to like,
no,
I was a George Carlin,
Richard Pryor,
man.
Maybe it was later.
It was bill Cosby.
Cosby for me was the first.
That was my first had an album and it was um,
it was Noah having a conversation with God.
You ever hear that?
No one
arc,
no having a conversation with God.
I vaguely remember it.
It's fucking great man.
I mean,
it's great.
He's a totally different style than any of us and I,
I don't think he's right in when he,
like,
he,
he gets mad at people for using certain language and yeah.
You know,
like there was a,
Wanda Sykes interviewed him once and uh,
he like criticized her language,
like how she,
you know,
phrase the question to him.
I'm like,
come on man.
But as a,
as a comedian,
like the dude's top notch,
he's all timely conservatives.
Very,
he's a very conservative,
very conservative.
Well you know what he is,
he's a super successful man that had to be incredibly driven to get to where he
was.
And he's not tolerating any mediocrity or what he perceives to be mediocrity in
any form,
whether it's language or behavior or the use of,
you know,
use of swear words.
Fun Guy.
And it's unfortunate.
I um,
uh,
my first experience with stand up was I was,
I can't remember,
I was very young.
My parents had a record player.
I put bill Cosby on and would play it.
And when you're a kid you don't have an immune system for comedy cause you've
never heard it before.
So the first time you hear it,
it knocks you on your ass.
Cause it's so funny you can't stop laughing.
You don't have the defense mechanisms.
It's a brand new thing.
You're hearing a whole new rhythm,
a whole new way of storytelling that is always the funniest thing you've ever
heard.
I can remember laying there and not being able to breathe,
just like clutching my stomach because it was so funny and it was like the one,
his joke that I remember from,
from this album was the one about getting drunk.
Just,
it was just this whole story about throwing up and getting drunk.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well he had that great bit about the,
the sun at the football game that the dad works out,
the sun does all this thing,
the sun,
and then finally,
you know the cameras turn on him and he's like,
hi mom.
Yeah,
we had one that I remember the one that I got hooked on gangs he got,
but that's the one that really fucked Mincey up that that one really fucked him
up.
Which one was it?
Cosby one.
Cause the co that's,
that's sacred ground.
I mean,
as far as standup Comedians,
in my opinion,
there's five,
six sacred comedians and Cosby's one of the sacred ones.
Sure.
Yeah,
no doubt about it.
He's a,
he's a all time genius.
You know this,
you can't talk shit about him,
but what an odd decision to steal a bill.
Bill Cosby joke.
He fucked up.
He,
he,
I,
you know,
we've,
we've said a lot of things about that guy over the years.
Mitzia you know,
I,
I honestly hope he's got his shit together.
You know,
I wish him well,
I don't have a,
you don't have to play that Dude's bug bug joke with the blue thing is one
really flip comedy for me.
He does a bit about playing buck buck.
He sits on the stool [inaudible] he doesn't move anybody who ever play buck
buck and was just a moving game.
Right.
He sold me in my mind and that's when I learned the other phase of comedy.
But at time I was maybe 16 or 17 but guess who I was into at that point?
Oh,
David Letterman,
Letterman.
When I let them in first came on.
So weird.
We'll let them fucking tell me about it.
What led them in first hit TV.
I was a senior in high school and the first time I was let them and I was gone.
Really like that style of seeing cool guy.
Yeah.
Something.
And then I watched him from 18 to like 23 you know,
whenever I was home at 11 when I wasn't coked up or in jail,
whatever I was doing and not in jail.
And then I didn't watch him again,
but I knew that style when he would come up and do his monologue in the
beginning I dug him like I fucking just was sold and I found that it was at the
comedy store and Pri was at the comedy store and I started putting all the
pieces together.
Wow.
And already I have heard the guy from [inaudible] was a joke thief.
He's a fucking joke.
Follow me.
Right.
So I heard that already.
And then again,
way before I was going to be a fucking comic,
not even thought I went to catch that dude.
And we've said this already on here,
wanting to see the dude from Boston.
It's very witty.
Steven.
Steven,
right,
right.
Yeah.
You went,
I,
my friend won tickets to the radio in boulder at the big thing on south boulder.
We went,
he was brilliant.
His material was brilliant.
I was blown away.
Wow.
He didn't fucking curse really towards the end.
That's a different style,
you know,
and I'm an all of a sudden I went to see him a year later they do the same
material and that was this.
And I said to myself,
I was ever a comic.
I wouldn't do the same volume number.
I think he has a real problem with that act.
So it's such a narrow window or that he can write material in,
you know,
what are the things he could write about?
Everything has to be observed.
Everything has to be like a little flip on things,
you know?
Yeah.
I,
yeah,
I'm always,
I love comics like that.
Like him and Mitch Hedberg,
they're,
they're amazing.
But I think it must feel a little cross to phobic to get stuck in that form.
Like Steven Reich,
I guess he can't just come out and start doing it a long story because people
will be like,
what the fuck?
What if he did it with like a lot of energy.
Yeah.
He's like,
and I was like,
lady,
what the fuck are you tired?
Everybody's like,
Whoa,
whoa.
Where's that mellow guy?
Yeah.
That's so I think that sucks kind of to get stuck or to get pigeonholed in that
one form and once weren't in a fire hydrant factory park anywhere near the
place.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's a classic Steven,
right?
That style in a of ways.
Very uh,
Bergin Hedberg
kind of to like real fucking sell good eye level shit.
My favorite Hedberg one is,
well,
it's one of my favorites.
He goes,
somebody asked me if I bought it a frozen banana.
I
said,
no,
but I want a regular banana later.
So yes,
I
can imagine if somebody wrote that down for you,
if you're hiring a guy to write jokes and listen to his fellow,
I'm gonna give you a 200 an hour,
right?
Make some snippy material.
I really need to kill him at the club tonight.
And he reads that.
Ask a guy asked me if I want a frozen banana,
what the fuck am I supposed to do with this guy asked me if I want a frozen
banana.
I say no,
but I'm on a regular banana.
Leda so yes.
What the fuck are you?
What the fuck am I paying?
You knew,
right?
Jesus Christ you piece of Shit.
Let me,
while it's brilliant,
it comes at a Hedberg,
the one about doubletree.
How did they name that?
What do you want to call the place?
Two trees.
Doubled tree meeting adjourned.
It's
his stuff and his stuff never connected.
Like what we do is like we'll have a subject.
It's so much easier the way we do comedy because you have a subject and like,
like your subject,
like the Liberace bet that you're doing now.
You start on,
he'll start on that Liberace movie and he can talk about that fucking movie for
15 minutes.
Yeah.
It's a whole series of hilarious things that exist inside of this one subject.
But if you're a Mitch Hedberg Guy,
it's like you're essentially,
you're talking about one thing and then you're talking about Oreo cookies and
then you're talking about,
you know,
heroin,
whatever and all the bullets you've got to have in your gut.
Man.
You've got to have so many jokes for an hour set.
If your age of your jokes is eight seconds.
Yeah.
And they're all on non connected.
But meanwhile Hedberg would just pump it out,
man.
Yeah,
he popped out a lot of shit.
He constantly was writing.
That guy was like one of the most prolific guys.
You know,
like you always heard about him writing a lot of it.
Yeah.
I heard somebody say they would write with him and they would go meet him to
write and they would have like want maybe one shitty half thought out,
joke written down and you would have like 20 just hilarious jokes.
You just,
he's one of those comics get it just pours out of him.
Are you breathing in the mic?
Jesus Christ.
I know what of the questions you,
the guilt
Darth Vader in the background.
Yeah,
he had that style down.
He figured out his perfect style and that's a great example of why you can never
really teach comedy.
You know,
I thought about doing,
I remember we talked about doing this at the store,
like doing something in the belly room.
Well I was,
I was going to call it like a comics workshop and the idea was like you really
can't,
like anyone who's like a real legitimate comic could go and do it for free.
He can't pay for that.
Can't be charged people for comedy classes.
Yeah.
It just seems too fucking weird.
It's just seems too strange.
It's like the entire opposite.
The feeling of
comradery that we're supposed to be giving each other.
We're not supposed to be taking money from each other like that.
Right.
You don't feed off of each other.
Well,
we should be doing is promoting the artists stand up.
You know,
if somebody wants to take a course and they're not a convenient and they just
want to find out what it's like and sit in,
then I could see maybe charging them.
But someone who was actually comedian trying to be a comedian,
there's that.
So the idea of teaching a class kind of goes against the whole way of,
you know,
the,
the whole way of camaraderie that we all enjoy.
But it's also that you can't teach people how to do comedy.
You can only give them advice as to maybe how you would do it or maybe if they
shorten things up or had less words.
Well,
it's,
it's a little bit like what you're,
it's funny,
I'm sorry to cut you off.
[inaudible] rambling.
What you're saying reminds me a lot of what people say about like Buddhism or,
uh,
spirituality is that they,
they,
they say,
you know,
you can't read this.
This isn't something like,
you can read all you want,
but it's not going to teach you.
It's the practice of the thing itself.
The teachers use.
So like,
oh,
when I went,
when I went down to hang out with to this Ron doss retreat and there is the Zen
Roshi there.
This is this woman who's been practicing zen for like,
I don't know,
her whole life basically.
And she said that the teacher does not give the student and enlightenment but
sets the conditions,
creates a good condition for realization.
So in the same way I think you could have a comedy class,
but the comedy classes and something where you tell someone,
here's how you hold the mic and here's the way you write a joke and here's how
you get booked at clubs,
it's more like here's an environment that is conducive to coming up with ideas
and jokes.
I'm kind of free form chaotic place where people just get together and,
and I guess,
you know,
get to be around people like you or like you know,
Cosby or big comics because somehow just being around a very funny person for a
little bit of time can teach you so much.
But the actual mechanics of the thing,
the technical aspects of it,
that's I think where comedy classes or
some,
I'm going to say this sincerely from my heart that as you were saying is going
to agree with me because we're both on the same page.
I would have loved if somebody would have taken my hand in the beginning and
walk me through a lot of things and there's a lot of things that I could take on
a new comic that we,
all three of us,
all four of us,
everybody in the room.
You could take a new comic and walking around for a couple of weeks with them
three,
four weeks and explain this after that.
It's like,
Hey,
auntie house man,
you got to figure it out on your own.
I got it.
Because that's part of the journey.
That's part of your happiness.
That's Kinda what's going to make you happy later.
Yeah,
you too guys are perfect example of it.
You two are two of my best friends and you're also two of my favorite comedians.
Thank you.
And you're both completely fucking different and I,
I love both of you.
Perform equally.
You're both totally different.
Totally different.
Totally different styles,
but yet both.
Awesome.
You know why?
Because you're really you and you're really you.
It's that simple.
You're not playing.
We all know the poor people that are stuck putting together like an act and
they're kind of pretending to be someone they're not.
And we know those folks and it's a,
it's a terrible Rut to be in now at artistically as a person,
whatever,
we,
you guys aren't in that spot.
So because of that,
you're allowed to figure out,
and I don't know if that's ever going to be you.
You almost have to struggle uniquely and individually to get to,
to become a Duncan Trussell.
It's almost like if you,
if you get advice like they're never going to figure out that this is possible,
that,
that you could be you.
Like if you met with someone when you were 20 years old and you're like,
Duncan,
would you like to do some day?
I like to smoke pot and play video games.
I like to write about my penis.
I would like to go on stage and make people laugh.
And that's really it.
They'd be like,
well,
okay,
kill yourself.
That's,
that's cute.
But let's think realistically Dunkin.
Right.
What about your real future?
Instead of saying,
oh so many people who've done it before this good,
no,
no one is ever going to be able to figure out how to make a Duncan Trussell
except on controls.
Right?
Well I think some people,
I think some,
I think comedians,
there are tendencies and Comedians,
there are similarities and Comedians,
right?
Wouldn't you say there's,
there's things in comics,
not,
not material wise,
but there are aspects of comedians that are all seem to be the same.
One is there,
they tend to be very anti authoritarian.
So like when when you tell them what to do,
when you tell them this is what you have to do,
they,
they inevitably want to reject that,
overcome it,
disrupted,
make fun of it.
And,
and I think that tendency starts,
oh,
when you're really young and if that tendency is in you,
you're going to have a hard fucking time anyway getting a regular job because
it's so such an a front.
Like I can remember listening,
I in in college there was a career class we had to go to and I can remember
sitting there and listening to the guy talk about having to wear suits and
talking about the way you talk to your boss and talking about the way to be
polite in the workplace and I,
I dunno,
I said,
okay,
no.
What happens when you listen to that guy?
You wind up at a restaurant with your date and some asshole actors starts
telling your date that she's an old soul and you just take it
yes.
With a bitch.
Slap it out,
dude.
Yes,
exactly.
That's because that's a big turn.
You,
you're right.
The essence of the thing is just lay on your belly and submit to the master.
Just the very same thing that like when you see a mother doc,
like our dog had puppies and I remember watching the mother dog play with the
puppies and part of the thing it seemed like she was teaching them was the like
show their belly to like turn turnover on their belly.
That's the essence of the fucking thing.
It's like a a [inaudible] subservient submission.
Well,
it's the only way you're ever going to get by in life with a regular job.
The only way to get by in life,
if you want to move your way up the corporate ladder,
you have to follow the rules.
You can't tell dirty jokes at work.
You can't try to get laid.
You can't try to play pranks on people.
There's no room for creativity.
You're there from nine to five.
You punching you.
I think these are,
that's not all places though,
man.
I just saw,
oh no,
it's certainly not Google.
I saw pictures of like somebody working in Google and they were laying in a box
of colored balls on there.
That's amazing.
I don't think it's,
I don't think it's all places.
It's an old school model.
It's an old school model,
which is that it's based on feudalism.
It's based on the king show obedience to the king shall obedience to your boss
or your teacher.
Yeah.
Google is the perfect example of how to do a corporation,
you know?
I mean we joke around about them being skynet,
but the rear,
the reality of Google is they've managed in a short period of time to keep a lot
of fucking employees happy.
Yeah.
They have a huge business.
They own everything.
They've gotten maps that they've got fucking music.
They've got their own operating system for phones that develop their own
browser.
I mean,
Jesus fucking Christ.
Has anybody ever kicked ass on the internet the way Google has and yet they're
really cool.
They're employees.
If you go there,
their employees get fucking foosball tables and shit and really good food and
they can,
you know,
they have a real comfortable working environment.
I have a friend that works there.
There's a dude that works there who's decided at work.
He wants to be a girl.
So he's a guy,
he's married,
he's got kids,
but at work he puts on women's clothes and they changed the title,
his title at work to what his girl name is,
what the fuck.
And they're like,
okay,
it's wheat.
They're so open minded.
They're not like,
Bob,
is there something going on man,
you know,
all of a sudden you're wearing a jet instead of any of that.
There's none of that.
They're like,
okay,
well how Lynn?
Um,
pleasure to meet you.
Helen.
If I met you before,
I have met you before,
but I met you as Bob.
Okay,
so now we'll pleasure to meet you asked Helen.
So let's,
let's take it from here on.
We're Helen except dinner parties when they go out at night and he brings his
wife,
then he dresses like a man,
like if the as functions or anything,
then he's a man and he's married.
He has a y and they're so open minded.
They are like,
okay,
as long as you're not putting you on it all this is your friend or this is a no,
no,
no.
My friend is my friend friend.
I'm like,
are you friends with your buck in the same environment as this person?
What's my friend works at Google?
That's all cool to you?
Slip and fall in the bathroom tiles.
Sue.
Google will not like sue.
You were addressing fucking word.
You want to sue me?
You want him to wear a dress?
Cock sucker.
You're you to get your shit together back your pencil.
That's what happens when your heels don't fit.
You'll imagine what the fuck you were fucking dressed.
The work.
Somebody's going to say something eventually.
I mean,
well the shoes alone would be reason to not be a woman.
If I was a woman I would even if I was like a really sexy,
like a heterosexual woman,
I think I would dress like a man.
I think.
I think this is like the most comfortable way to move around.
Yeah,
no converse.
All stars.
Pair of jeans,
nice comfortable shorts.
Why are you wearing those shoes?
Well those crazy shoes you wear and you can't walk in.
Yeah,
the co I,
you know,
I,
one thing that is probably certain,
but I guess I'll find out in a second is that those fucking shoes were not
invented by a woman.
Right?
Like whoever been at high heels wasn't a Wa wasn't,
oh,
no person was like,
you know what?
I'm going to put myself in uncomfortable stilts that warp my feet.
I'm going to,
I'm going to put myself in the most uncomfortable shoe where I can't drink.
Yeah.
Probably as a chick probably wasn't.
It's no.
A lot of people like foot bindings there.
There's a whole history of like,
ah,
I meant to say it isn't a check.
Yeah.
Med say while Jimmy Choo is a woman.
Did you know that?
Who?
Jimmy Choo.
That's like a big one with the,
with the gals.
They love the Jimmy Choo shoes.
Jimmy Choo's actually a woman.
A woman created that.
Yeah,
but if you look at the history of them,
what's,
find out what he can be a patent on this.
I hate Google.
You get as a stoner or any of your stupid ideas can instantly be shot down.
My friend ate it using or wearing high heels the other day,
tore her knee wide open because of this stupid high heels.
Shoes.
Yeah,
they're fucking dangerous man.
Yeah.
It's like,
especially when you're walking around on the street and there's cracks in the
sidewalk and weird shit and divots.
Yeah.
You can't walk in those things bitch.
You can't work in those things.
Okay.
Where does it say invention?
The history in high yield history.
You've haunted me with those feet.
Shoot Joe.
They'll footie toady.
I see him like every day now.
They're great.
If you wore them,
you would wear what?
You're so funny to talk shit because you weren't slippers right now wearing
slippers,
like you just stepped out.
If some Russian bathhouse when they give you,
give you one of those,
those massages,
would they beat you with the gov sticks like a fade or you to do the and Nice
fucking slap you with that.
The shoes are,
I bet they are company,
but that's what it looks like.
Are you shuffling out in the middle of the winter and some Soviet Union gear
headed to the Banya?
Yeah.
If it gets slapped massage naked.
Or an Alzheimer's patient who slipped out the back door is lost in a city.
Yeah.
All right.
The first incidence of the wear of high heels involved 1533 marriage between
Catherine de Mer murky and the Duke of Orleans.
She wore heels made in Florence for her wedding.
And as a result,
the Italian high heels became the norm for the ladies in the Duke's Court and
France.
Unfortunately this reference may be a cripple.
Ooh.
Apocryphal Apocryphal as the development of heels did not begin to come about
until the late 1580s based on an iconic graphic evidence.
And so it was somewhere around the 18th,
the the 15 eight to 15
I heard it's because uh,
everything needs to be covered in shit and a lady didn't want to get her feet
and shit puddles.
And so you would try to use the high yields to like push the feet?
Yeah.
Doesn't make sense because the toes down,
toes still getting kicked and shit better the toes and the entire foot.
Really.
If I have to choose between how much of anything I want covered in shit,
I'm going to pick a camera,
I'll go with my heels.
I would rather have shit on my heel.
Then industry,
my little cute little toast cheese.
Why would you want to get your piggies
piggies wall?
I said what would that look like?
Reverse high heels.
That'd be really weird.
You have like some Gene Simmons style kiss boots,
you know co call my doc did love with teeth walking through the shit.
Yeah.
That was the cause of a lot of disease back in the day.
It was the poor sewer systems and the rotting bodies and all sorts of the things
they had to deal with when people died.
Just our river as shit man.
And people would also like the,
like,
especially in during times of war,
like their rivers would get clogged up with bodies,
you know,
and the bodies would rot and then if you drank river water with rotting bodies
and it,
you'd get sick as fuck and possibly die.
People say,
Oh look,
these shootings are happening today.
It's like you used to watch dead blown up bodies role by your home.
You used to,
when you walked outside,
you would walk up to your ankles and plague diarrhea.
Yeah.
It sucks that people are getting shot right now,
but it's nothing like what it used to be.
It's
definitely nothing like what it used to be,
but the numbers are so high that it seems like it's never ending.
It's a torrent because we're really not supposed to be paying attention to 7
billion people at the same time.
That's what I think you're our way or our way,
or is this going to be how we fix it?
Is that this going to be where people don't get ignored anymore,
where you really have to take and pay attention to the assets of every single
human being like assets,
meaning you know you as a person and asset to civilization that all of them have
to be accounted for and if they're not,
if they feel disenfranchised,
that's when you're going to have problems.
When they feel left out and they feel a avoided,
you're going to have fucking problems.
But people don't get the love that they need from the jump on top of all the
real serious mental illnesses that can plague people that just happen.
W I knew a dude who went crazy.
You remember the dude,
the tod?
Do remember the Todd?
You don't remember the towel?
I,
yes,
I actually met him wines.
The Todd is responsible for me getting into this store.
Wow.
Because when I was doing this,
yes.
Remember him,
friends at Pauley,
Greg Guy,
man.
He was a a comic and he was on MTV back in the day and he had been in and I went
up and I did a spot and Mitzi,
she like,
she gave me nonpaid regular status means I could go on after the show was over.
So I would go there every night,
wait till like one o'clock in the morning and get on and you know,
it was all right.
He was better than nothing,
you know,
I was happy to have that.
But then I got a second chance to audition for a couple months after that and
the Todd sat next to her on purpose and just laughed and laughed and he kept
like slapping the table and saying that I was funny.
Cause like sometimes Mitzi needs to hear from other people too.
She's like,
he's brilliant.
Meanwhile I was like half have the same material I did three months before that,
but it was better then.
I'm
sure I'd more gotten more comfortable with being at the store and show I was
nervous the first time.
I think she also had her ear to the ground.
Yeah.
If you were coming in there every night,
she knew it.
She knew it and she knew that was like part of a sign that somebody had
potential.
I think it was more than just that instantaneous watching thing.
I think it's a combination of sort of,
but the Todd actually sent me hip that that's been used before and he told me
that that's the way I should get my friends into.
So that's what I started doing.
Like when McGuire did it,
I sat right next to minutes and laughed hard at McGuire.
You know anybody who ever like was performing for her,
I would make sure I sat right next to her and laughed.
Man.
Was that not the weirdest fucking thing sitting next to Mitzi and then watching
the comics come up and like literally bow to her.
Like comics would come up,
old school,
cold leader,
Guru style.
Bow Down.
Touch her to like try to touch her and then she would do the Mitzi wave void.
You remember that?
Anna Mattie here.
Okay.
Hi Annie.
And watching a show.
You're talking about Todd rendering.
Rendering.
Who's that?
Why are we talking about him?
What are you talking about?
He was from MTV back in there.
No,
no,
no.
You want me to say about Todd Rundgren?
He was married to the chick.
What's the,
what's Tyler's Tyler?
Who's daughter?
Oh,
Liv Tyler.
Liv.
Tyler.
Just mother was living with that dude.
Okay.
And the mother took her to see Aerosmith and Lou Tyler turned around and told
the mother,
that's my father.
For years.
They had raised her thinking it was Todd Rundgren.
Whoa.
It was really Steven Tyler,
but she wanted her to figure it out.
True Story Bro.
I'd rung her is a bad motherfucker.
He's got some bad ass.
Jan,
I know you've heard his job.
What does it songs
we can we switch?
You could play something.
Yeah.
Just look up the names of what's the fuck you fuck.
You can do it.
If they can prove that you're making money off of it.
You absolutely camp one thing.
One thing.
There's something called fair use.
How's it work?
I,
I think that if you listen to dunk and he ain't got no legal experience.
Yes he does.
He on legal zoom Tamakoshi
Oh
hey,
I earned it.
If you're making a commentary over a thing,
there's some kind of like area where it is okay to like reprint staff,
but it has not in Berlin.
And I think you can do like,
there's seconds,
like 10 seconds.
It's all whatsapp thing.
That's interesting.
I wish it would get released.
The icehouse chronicles with,
we were talking about,
uh,
about,
um,
the,
what I feel is the greatest guitar solo in the history of music.
Pretty Bird.
I don't think anything could fuck with free Freebird and we were playing free
bird and we're just getting into the song,
but I'll crazy ones that there's this dirty,
stinky Longhair dudes from Florida who are making this insane music.
And all their songs were about getting away from [inaudible]
all their songs,
like a huge percentage of the songs.
Like,
I gotta be free.
Um,
they call me the breeze,
I must do this.
You take care.
And all their fucking songs are about getting away.
Give me two steps.
I mean,
everything is like,
I gotta get the fuck out of this town.
This shit got crazy.
What's your name?
I'll be back next year.
It's so funny that we're writing songs about this ancient evolutionary thing and
coded in our genetics,
which is that you want to put as much DNA into as many people as you can.
But now like people are actually probably monkeys would seem sing the same song
if they could any kind of primate with like it's kind of stuck in that awful
predicament of like having a genetic predisposition to spray just into as many
holes as possible.
It's just in there.
And then also the need to like start a family and love someone and be
monogamous.
That's one of the great internal wars that is raging around the world right now
is people trying to figure out how to deal with it,
how to reconcile those two.
How do you reconcile that shit?
Yeah,
you ha well it's also,
I think there's a certain amount of conflict that sort of ensures movement and
shores a lot of activity and when you have two systems that are dueling it out,
one trying to dominate the other one,
trying to find a way through whether it's through certain new words they
introduce into the lexicon,
whether it's or the language,
whether it's the way they,
you know,
how they interact with each other.
But what they're trying to do is everyone's trying to get a little bit ahead.
Men are trying to get a little bit ahead of women.
Women are trying to get a little bit ahead of men,
women and feel suppressed.
We'll try to suppress others.
Men who feel suppressed and tried to do the same,
and there's this crazy battle going on and I think it's almost like designed
that way.
Well,
it's a culture of dishonesty.
Don't forget,
you're not allowed to say these things.
This is,
but it's also the culture that produces the most stuff creatively.
It's very strange.
Yeah.
I think that's a very positive spin on it,
man.
But imagine like,
and then,
but the end,
but I should say right now,
it's not to discount any of the Europeans,
Japanese,
Asians,
whatever,
all the people all over the world that do creative shit.
Right.
But there's a certain,
there's no real,
there's no denying the fact that United States is responsible for an insane
amount of influential pop culture from the 1950s to the present.
Insane amounts.
Of course,
the Europeans,
of course,
the Beatles and the stones.
And of course the WHO.
Of course there's no denying that there was a million of them from the UK as
well.
But when you count in stand up comedy,
when you count in music,
all different kinds of music,
we,
there's a lot of weird shit that came out of the United States.
Do you think that's because you're saying that that's coming from,
it's almost oppression might
be something to that.
The need to conquer,
the need to conquer the crazy genetics that led to these people being willing to
get in ships and go halfway across the fucking world in a boat with fucking
barrels of food that might be enough for everybody to eat and you might not get
scurvy and you don't even have a fucking video that you can watch of what this
place,
where you going to try to live in looks like and you going over there with your
kids.
Yeah,
those are savages.
Those people were fucking crazy.
So you have that.
You have the legacy of these people and that's a part of it.
Like this,
this,
this desire to just move forward.
They're willing to take the most risks in order to get to America in the first
place.
I think the news will come as because of that.
People who came over here to I guess support your argument.
Uh,
many of the people who came over here where some of the most sexually repressed
people on earth because they were hardcore,
uh,
Christians.
This is like the scarlet letter.
This is like the,
the body was something to be reviled,
but I don't,
I don't know if it's their oppression that is made that brings inspiration,
that,
and that's never,
I've never been in a,
you know what maybe it is though,
because I can think of like times where you're like super horny or,
or like lonely and that does produce.
Think about music,
man.
Yeah.
Where's the music coming from?
Where's the greatest music coming from?
Fucking pain,
man.
Coming from fucking pain please baby.
Oh Man.
There's some,
there's some classic on,
you're my favorite mistake.
You ever heard that Sheryl Crow Song?
God damn man just gets off.
God Damn that bitch could sing.
She had this like soft warm voice.
It's like a hug that you get through your ears.
It's like this loving voice that she has and she's talking about this
relationship that's just fallen apart and that you're my favorite mistake.
And you heal the hear the emotions and the love through her voice.
You've got to have pain to feel that man.
You got to have pain to understand it.
You've got to have pain to be able to relate to it.
You've got to have experienced that.
If you're some fresh faced pop who's never skid his knee and never had a a
family member die,
you don't know what the fuck the possibilities of the world are.
You can't appreciate the full spectrum because you don't know how low the lows
can get.
Your lows are pretty fucking high.
So when you do hit a low,
it makes you appreciate the days that are high.
I was just reading this,
I'm reading this book called um,
the spirits cutting through spiritual materialism and it's by this Tibetan monk
named Chogyam Trungpa who,
um,
was just writing about this thing that you're saying and he was saying
disappointment.
Disappointment is one of the great states to be in to,
uh,
for for growth and for spirituality.
Because disappointment means you're having a contact with truth.
It generally means you're having a contact with truth.
Something has gone against your expectation,
which is how the universe works.
And then you find yourself in what he describes as like just the rocky terrain
of truth.
So now the relationship that you thought might work out,
but you knew it wouldn't,
it didn't,
or your mom has died,
or you just put your dog to sleep.
Now you're experiencing reality.
You're experiencing the fact that you are in a Maelstrom of Adam's,
that 10 that will inevitably dissipate and nothing is.
And that is a really intense fucking place to be in.
But he doesn't say stay in a place of disappointment.
He says that to move past that place into the next place,
which is the incredible peace and joy that comes from recognizing that you're
part of this infinite non-ending changing,
beautiful thing.
You've got to recognize the first part,
which is you're not going to last.
Nothing's going to last.
No one you know is going to survive this thing.
Everything that you've ever said will be lost in time.
We are all part of an infinite shifting,
changing thing.
And what's causing you the problems is your desire to hold on to a form,
to hold onto the idea of this is who I am.
This is how things are always going to be.
This is going to last forever.
That conception will always cause you pain if you have a hangover.
No.
If you're having a terrible trip and you start thinking,
I'm going to be freaking out forever,
man,
that will only make the trip worse.
And if you're with someone you love and you think I'm going to be with this
person forever,
you're setting yourself up for some pretty severe disappointment because you
won't.
And so that disappointment that comes from realizing that that's the place where
you start growing.
How do you Krishna
disappointed while you're freaking me out,
but the trestle buckle fucking with my head.
Duncan Trussell.
I walked through the heat of the sun was up.
I don't think we all need Elton John Song.
There's a,
there's an old expression that a wise man learns from the mistakes of others.
A fool learns from his own.
Yes.
You know,
I think that,
I don't know.
I don't know if we need to have massive fucking chaos for people to understand
and appreciate how cool life can be,
but it helps.
And the people that I know that are the most interesting,
all had fucked up lives.
All of us.
They all,
I fucked up lives.
None of nobody here in this room was on the Brady bunch.
Well,
it gets you out there,
man.
It's like,
you know,
you always hear about people who it's who get cancer and then all of a sudden
they're skydiving.
They're like running from the bulls.
They're doing anything they want.
They're talking guys,
right.
Telling the truth.
They're telling the truth.
And that's really,
that's really,
um,
I think that's like a,
that's a,
that's a tragic thing in the sense that for people to actually start
appreciating their existence,
they have to be a dying.
You know,
dying is in within a year.
We're all dying.
But it's like suddenly when you wake up to the fact that you're dying,
that's when you actually are born.
And a lot of people don't get that.
Yeah.
There's a wake up call.
There's that,
that reality check when this was the real game.
Yes.
Is the real shit man.
And you're really affecting people.
Well,
it's so easy to get complacent.
It's so easy to just get lazy.
So easily just look at life and not appreciate the fuck
out of this crazy ride we're on.
Yeah.
Especially us.
We're,
we're,
we're on the craziest ride of all the,
the ride of the professional comedian,
you know,
we get drugs from the audience,
we tell jokes and they give us drugs.
Like the drug of laughter,
that's a drug.
We're all addicted to it.
The drug of killing,
you know,
man,
I think it's a crazy ride,
but I think the whole,
any,
if you have been blasted out of a pussy onto this planet,
you're having a crazy ride.
Everyone you are.
There's no way to not have a crazy ride.
And the was just young and Brian put her on camera.
Why you talking to me about rise died.
Trussell I'm going to ride back home to my bed.
You keep talking and I'll fuck you too fucking they're obese.
Just started smoking weed a week.
He would say that for the first like 10 years,
Joe Rogan been smoking weed for a year.
You've been smoking weed for two years.
Joe Rogan,
you've been smoking weed for three years.
Shut the fuck up.
Joe Rogan.
It's only been 10 years.
You don't even know about weed yet.
I have four more years.
Then you understand the nuance,
the subtleties,
sorry.
In a fucking Twat is Rogan.
It's been fucking half your life.
There's a whole half of your life you did without weed,
so shut the fuck up.
You did and all.
Yeah.
It's amazing what you did do without the,
we'd like now to shut it off for a while.
God.
God,
hello.
We're really happened.
Yeah.
God,
Praise Eddie Bravo.
Praise Zeus and praise Odin.
Freddy Bravo.
Because if it wasn't for him,
I would've never started smoking weed.
I thought it was for losers.
That'd be so weird to see the difference in your life.
Yeah,
I'd probably be like way more aggro.
It's,
um,
it's a beneficial substance,
man.
And that's the real problem that I have with people that want to go on and on
about people who are addicted to it.
Like,
you know,
I love doctor drew.
I think he's a good person.
I really do.
But whenever I hear him talk about people being addicted to weed,
I'm like,
let's get all those people that are addicted to it in the room and find out what
the fuck else is going on.
I guarantee you,
you,
you shouldn't blame weed.
It's not a physically addictive thing.
I always feel something.
I always feel that you have an addictive personality.
You know,
we've discussed when you were on the cone with the listening and quake quake
dropping this on me and I'm like,
where's this dog?
You don't know.
When I used to leave you guys at the store,
I go home and I played til seven in the morning.
And for people to recognize that that's what it,
that's what a gift comes in because somebody would write that off.
Like,
that's just what he does every fucking night in the morning.
And it's weird how I have always believed,
especially for me,
it's always been the transfer of addictions.
Okay.
And then at the end of the game,
he was just the simplest way of solution.
If you're going to have a fucking light addiction,
you might as well let it be the cheapest and the less harmful and the mines,
it's always been the weight,
you know,
it makes me better at night when I ride,
it makes me,
they'll calms me down in the daytime,
you know,
whatever.
I make it believe that it does.
It fucking does.
If it's not a make belief,
I know you.
I see what happens when you get high.
Well,
it first of all,
never see you sober.
Not You sent me so three times,
but you've seen him.
He's documented them.
I wrote them down.
Believe Joey Diaz is sober and then I look at his pocket.
He's got an empty chair.
But you rappers,
I might be incorrect number is a relative term,
but it's really weird.
Like sometimes I go,
you know what,
Monday,
I'm not going to leave smoking that though.
Eat nothing and by Tuesday is not like I'm Jonesing.
I'll just find myself with a joint,
a five or the afternoon when I'm writing something more,
but I like it guys.
Out of all the addictions,
whether it's going to strip clubs,
drinking,
gambling.
I could been hooked on a thousand fucking things.
We ended up with reefer.
I enjoy it as a ritual.
I enjoy it as a ritual before I write.
I enjoy it as a ritual like before we do podcasts.
I like it as a ritual.
I like it.
It's like signifies that we're,
we're going to shut off our phones and get into this space.
Whether it's a space of doing stand up by the space of writing or the space of
doing a podcast.
I like it in that way,
but also like the facts.
The facts are undeniable man for me is that introspective aspect of it that you
talked about earlier is so important.
Very important.
I've been talking about it on stage.
The,
the term paranoia.
You know the people like,
I don't like weed.
It makes me paranoid.
I'm like,
you really should be paranoid.
If you're paying attention,
do you really want to just open yourself up to all the possibilities?
It's insanity out there.
Everywhere you go,
you're a bag of blood,
a fleshy bag that's holding a couple of gallons of blood,
and if any of it spills out,
you're fucking doomed and you're running around in metal boxes.
Everybody's flying by going 60 plus miles an hour.
They don't know what the fuck they're doing.
They're running over motorcycles.
You see that shit in New York.
She that she see that shit and for motorcycles,
the motors.
Well,
he ain't,
there was some craziness that went on.
I don't know who started water,
who did what,
but I know that that dude ran over.
I've got the bikers could have been,
however,
how he handled it might have been incorrect also,
I don't know what happened.
The Guy,
the guy got,
apparently someone slowed down in front of him and he bumped the bike and then
the guy stopped his bike and they,
they're,
they're the,
the assumption is that the guy did it on purpose being a dick and he was trying
to box in this guy in the truck and make him slow down.
We also don't know what their interaction was before this video started.
We don't know if this had been going on for a while,
like maybe the,
the biker panicked and cut someone off the bike or was an agent driver.
I'm not saying,
I'm not saying the agent drivers are terrible,
but a lot of Asian drivers are terrible.
Are We?
Are we,
are we in agreement on this?
But that doesn't mean it's not,
it's not that.
It's not that all of them are terrible,
but it,
that is the goddamn stereotype.
Okay.
And I'm not saying that this guy is responsible goddamn stairs.
It's like 99.9% it's the God damn stereotype.
And it's not,
it's not 100% true,
of course.
Just like it's not 100% true that all Italians beat their wives.
Okay.
But that,
and me being Italian,
I can say that,
but,
but the reality is is that this guy,
we in the video drives over there,
they're yelling at him and he drives over this bike and drives over a guy and
broke his body.
Mean the guy he drove over him with a fucking SUV.
Yeah.
I don't know if that had to have happened.
I don't know.
I don't know what happened before that.
I certainly think it's a terrible tragedy on both ends that the guy in the car
got beat up and that the guy got ran over.
It's a terrible tragedy.
But besides my,
my horrible racist Asian joke,
which I apologize for profusely,
I was just joking around and making a point,
but I don't know what happened.
I really don't know what happened.
So,
but when I'm looking at,
I'm looking,
I look at a guy who drove over somebody and then I looked at another guy went
insane and beat the guys window in like,
why has a baby in the car?
So to me it says tragedy on both sides.
It's a tragedy.
It's a tragedy of over,
over reacting on both sides.
For sure.
A horrible tragedy.
Yeah,
it sucks.
Horrible tragedy that the guy who got pulled out of his car and beat up,
horrible tragedy,
that guy got polos calling.
He got pulled out and he got beat up.
You got up face?
Yeah.
Well there was all this glass that broke too,
cause the guy broke the window.
He's breaking the window with his helmet and smashing the window with his
helmet.
It's,
the whole thing is crazy.
And the whole thing is spike strip out.
Did they really?
That's what I rad.
What's a spike strip?
Potts popped his tires.
Who threw it out?
The bikers.
They had a spike strip line is what I read.
Okay.
You are not googling this.
You're not even trying to substantiate this.
Google it.
Okay,
I'll pull it up.
Okay.
Bikers threw down spike strip.
Okay,
here we go.
You know,
I'm watching this and I'm thinking,
you know,
you,
your wife,
your kid,
what the fuck?
I know they're there.
Also there was,
there was um,
um,
tinted windows so they might not be able to see that this guy had his wife and
his kid in the car.
Um,
it doesn't say that Duncan,
I read it.
Isis plates on the things,
uh,
biker Bra.
They popped his tires.
That's why I couldn't keep going.
No,
I'm apparently someone stabbed his tire.
Did.
That was one of the,
uh,
one of the,
that's not real.
Dot.
Brian,
you can't trick me.
I know what a video game looks like.
You Fuck it looks pretty God damn good though.
Look how good that looks.
Isn't an amazing,
like the textures of the road.
It's so beautiful.
Oh,
show the timelapse show.
Have you seen that?
The timelapse I'm still fascinated.
I'm never going to get into this game.
I've,
well I cannot do it because it's just too,
it's,
it looks like it's too good.
Have you not having had him lay down at all?
No,
I know me man.
I don't fuck around.
I know me.
I'm crazy.
What about this oculus rift thing in Kuwait?
I said,
I know me bitch.
Quake is supposed to be oculus rift friendly at all the things I'm allowing
myself at.
All the things that get me crazy addicted.
I'm allowing myself to just fuck with pool because the pool is,
I think I get something out of it that I don't get out of video games.
I get like a a body calmness because it's all about like meditating on the
distance that the ball was going to go and calming yourself down and putting
yourself into a very sensitive state where you're playing.
I don't get that from video games,
so when I looked at it objectively,
I'm like,
like Joey said he got addictions.
You know,
you've got to pick which is the best one.
And for me the best one is pool.
Yeah.
Oh Nice.
Is it to go to a,
I mean,
I don't even like a nice pool halls if I'm going to go to a pool or I want to
see it for what it is,
but I don't mind stupidity like hard times.
You ever go to hard times with me?
You have been a hard time.
Where have we gone?
Went to the old Hollywood billiards,
which was an awesome,
right?
We went to the place in New York City 10 years ago cause it go in Manhattan and
then we went somewhere else.
That was Chelsea.
We went to Chelsea billiards.
That was a Chelsea billions after.
Yeah.
Chelsea billions after.
I think it had already changed names.
Chelsea billiards was the legendary places.
Like sometimes they'll see me wear this jacket.
It's like a varsity jacket that says Chelsea billiards in the back.
Have you seen that?
That at an all time great pool halls for pool hustlers and action.
That's the greatest or one of the greatest next to hard times in California,
one of the greatest in the history of the world.
That places a 24 hour pool hall where half the people in there,
you'd go at three o'clock in the morning,
half the people in there were vagrants that could rob you,
but I mean Robbie playing pool,
they could get out homeless dudes who knew how to fucking get out.
They knew how to play safety,
know that fuck you up.
They would get you on those tables.
Especially at gap,
what they would call a gaff table is a table where one pocket rolls to the
right.
And if you know that pocket rolls to the right,
you could put someone in a position where they don't think they can make the
ball but they can't.
And you know it a little shit.
Things like you can scratch on shots where you don't think you can have,
you know,
a table,
especially what they call a gaff table.
It's,
it's huge,
very important.
If you're a pool player on the team advantage,
which is rob people,
they would rob people.
But there was also like really high stakes gambling between like high level pros
to really interesting stuff to watch both the drunks getting robbed and then you
know,
by the,
the,
the hustlers and then the real big sharks come in and they would,
you know,
match up and put the money on the light.
And you know you're in,
you're in the middle of fucking New York City.
Dude,
it's four o'clock in the morning and dudes are playing for $10,000 and when
you're a kid and you're watching that and you know it's a,
it's an exciting shit.
That was a part for me.
It was like being a part of this really rare underground society that I knew was
not going to last very long.
Like I'm like this crazy 24 hour pool hall life where people were players and
the gambling and they're bringing their own money and then that matching up and
he barking at each other.
You ain't got no heart and they're fucking get in there.
That's a crazy underground world.
These guys were making a living,
paying their bills completely off the grid,
no taxes,
no nothing.
No one's no tax it.
Stop,
stop,
stop.
I'm staying at this fucking boarding house down the street does.
I'm in a,
I'm in a house with 10 other dudes.
I got my pool cue,
I put it under my blanket when I sleep.
I get up in the morning and I go down to Chelsea and you're like,
whoa,
these guys were living there.
They were getting an education in this gangster life at this 24 hour pool hall.
I know several dudes.
You've got arrested while I was playing there.
One Dude who was a three card Monte champion.
He would,
he was a bad motherfucker.
Three card money.
He's just slick Puerto Rican dude.
He would go out and he'd just have all these dumb white people from Nebraska
that had never been to New York City before and he would be doing this three
card Monte Shit and this is all before the Internet and they couldn't,
you know they would come on right up here sir.
You look like a winner.
You looked like you know how to play a game,
my friend.
Come on over here dog.
How much money you got on you,
my friend,
my friend.
Where are you from?
Do you got a beautiful suit?
That's a beautiful suit.
Does that a,
is that Amani?
What is that bro?
Yo,
that's beautiful.
Hey listen man,
this is a game called three car.
Mine.
We just like to have a little fun here in New York City.
Especially.
People come in for the first time.
They're showing you real simple,
real simple.
This is the three of them and now they're giving it to you Duncan.
They can give it to Jessie.
I'll give you a couple of free one gets it.
There it is.
Bam.
There you go.
You will just want him some money and all of sudden there's a partner next to
him.
So how do we do it?
You see the partner getting close to then y'all got to Blackton,
right?
You got a Pete and Duncan,
he showed it to you and the next thing you know Dunkin,
it all goes to hell.
Well this is the cups and there's also three card money.
There's the cups we tried to figure out to is free carb mine on Sunday.
The 20 goes down and the guy wins and the next 20 goes down again and the guy
doubles his money and that's it.
Now he gets the guy from the brass would come in and throw 40 and he ones and
the wife is like,
do it again,
do it again.
Cause everybody wants to come to New York.
You ever seen a guy try to walk away with
Yo,
they will attack
that table going,
this is a table Dunkin.
So right there they'd have two guys suck then and one of their own.
So you'd be working with me and you're 20 you'd be doubling up.
You're already won one this.
But I know I got three people in the audience and I at the Tyson and I'm letting
them know they're going to win.
They just come to New York.
You know what?
I got $200 in my pocket.
If I double it,
that's $400 I mean this is how you're thinking right there.
It's a do or die situation.
And all of a sudden right there when they got you,
boom,
the black Bam,
they take up 1200 the Puerto Rican yells the police and they take that money and
sweet tourist to like what the fuck?
And they're gone just happened.
Hey,
and the guy's got a carton,
like a bottom of a carton for cans and he just throws it up in the air and
that's it.
That's their residence.
It's a carton,
the three cups of gun and the beans and their fucking mouth,
and they're walking on the street and there ain't no fucking cops and they're
all gone in different directions and now they hook up again and I will at the
same place.
And they do that same scamming and they would do that five times,
make six grand.
That's how good it was.
I got caught on one day with a buddy of mine.
They took me for 20 the guy was yelling at me,
next know guys that was with laid out 20 a piece,
Bam,
60 bucks and next thing you know,
boom,
the police,
they blow a whistle.
What's going on here?
The cops,
everybody runs I think tremendous.
They got your money.
Fucking tremendous man.
You know when you made that turn on 42nd street?
It was,
it was when you were 1312 it was something that already says that when you walk
around to it,
you walked past people you know and all of I'm sudden like go under that breath.
They'll go weed and like five feet.
You've look around and go look at you and Austin.
They come back up to you.
It was completely different when you cut that corner on 42nd street,
Dunkin you to hit every drug in the world.
Weed,
marijuana to
joints,
loose joints,
acid.
Because the acid in the Spanish,
I see them.
No fucking Aussie though.
Fucking marihuana headwind.
Okay.
Now but equal fucking with different God.
I was stupid rich like Bill Gates rich.
I would by Chelsea billiards and I would reinstate it.
I would bring it back.
I'd make it 24 hours a day.
I'd make it the last bastion of the pool house is open.
It's like some fo pool hall now where they have like red cloth and fucking shiny
lights and they play horrible music.
That makes me want to throw up.
If you go to a pool hall and not playing Classic Rock,
turn around,
turn around and leave.
Just if you walk in,
if you don't hear some layered scattered,
some Smith,
if you don't hear sweet home Alabama,
get out of there cause they got red cloth and you plan on buckets and no one's
level these fucking tables.
It's a disaster.
It's not real pool.
I only didn't he get is an old hamburger or fucking bag of fries.
The place that I used to play out in white plains,
New Jersey or white plains,
New York got turned into a disco.
It's basically a disco now.
It was executive billiards executive.
Billy is in white plains right down the street from Nicky's pizza.
The greatest white pizza the the earth has ever known.
If you want to,
if you want to get off your gluten free diet,
go to fucking white plains,
New York.
Go to Nicki's pizza and get the white pizza.
It's got white cheese on it.
Ricotta cheese with garlic and olive oil and it will knock your Dick Right into
the cat litter box.
It's an unfuck unbelievably good.
It's better than better than digging the dirt.
I was just struggling for a metaphor.
Cat Litter box better than your dick in a pile of shit.
Those crumbs stick into the tip of your helmet.
The uh,
the,
the place was like a great place back in the day,
in the 90s.
That was the spot.
Like pool hustlers would come in from all over the world.
They would come,
like there was step make stops in New York if were in the New York area,
there's a few places they would play and one of them was,
they would always check in and executive and you know,
if you were,
my buddy owned the place,
so he'd be on the phone,
you know,
and then get a call,
in the,
in like the middle of the day,
you know,
he's a Polish and balls and shit.
And he'd get a call that Jake,
the snake is in town,
you know,
this is dude Jake the snake who played one pocket and you'd come down and you
know,
and they would call George the Greek.
This guy wants to play one pocket way.
This motherfucker's got no hot and then everybody would meet up at the pool hall
like 10 o'clock at night and you'd see the dude practicing knocking balls around
the table like,
oh shit,
it's going down.
And then they would put this big stack of money and there was this Guido
gangster dude who was always there.
He had a gun just in case somebody tried to rob a steak.
It was fucking crazy place to be a part of.
Sounds cool.
I was fucking,
it was run you nest.
It was a movie.
I mean it was,
it was like a crazy movie about the depression except there's no depression.
It was just going to diners and watching guys gamble their life away.
And me being a visitor in the world,
I was not really a player.
I couldn't play that good.
I played okay.
Like for a regular person I played amazing.
But for these guys I would play and I would always lose.
And I've never,
I won like one or two tournament's ever.
Most of the time I would lose.
I'd have to get really lucky to win.
So I got the chance to see these people lived entirely off of this one crazy
game.
That's all they did.
All they talked about was the different conditions of the cloth and what kind of
chocolate you using and what we're fucking tip have you got,
you've got a sniper on this motherfucker.
When did you get the sniper?
Is that better?
And they would try.
Everybody's trying to constantly figuring out an edge because they're playing a
game where their life with the eat or no,
whether they go hungry,
whether they have money for a hotel room is all based on fractions of an inch
with a ball roll slightly to the left too far or bumps the other ball and gets
in the perfect position.
The the fucking differences between those things are the tiniest fraction and
the cue ball where you hit it and they're obsessed with it,
obsessed with the movements and just trying to live off those movements.
That gives me an anxiety attack.
It's madness,
but it's also beautiful when you watch it done right.
It's an art form.
That's what people don't understand about the game.
When people say,
Oh,
you're fucking boring.
You talk about pool.
It's just so fucking boring to me.
It's not,
trust me when you,
it's,
it's one of those things when you appreciate it,
when you know how difficult it is to do,
then it becomes an art form of ballet.
Exactly.
When you talk about scarp starcraft,
I go blank because I have no point of reference.
I don't understand the game.
I've never tried it.
I'm terrified of it.
I see you.
I see you fucking start sweating when you talk about it.
I see your face starts sucking in like your body is trying to conserve water
cause you know you're not going to be your body.
You say starcraft and your body goes into like the hybrid native state where it
knows it's not going to get nutrition for the next three days.
Don't you lie that stuff you would stay quit.
I didn't quit because of the addiction.
I quit because they demoted me to a bronze league again.
I'm not dealing with that shit anymore.
I'm like number 75 and bronze league.
I had made it up to the silver and then I,
man,
your ego reveals you my brother.
Why do you give a fuck if you're in bronze loop,
you BM bronze league,
Joe.
It's an end.
So I wouldn't even be in Bronson getting beaten by the dealers.
I would be an aluminum scrap aluminum playing against fourth graders who are
crushing me.
I used to play against somebody.
No,
it's why you ageist.
It's a young man's sport.
You're in the Atrius patriarchal household.
Your male a just privilege is showing you.
You basically hate women,
but it in your blog.
I don't care.
Basically hate women.
I'm going to have to blog about you Duncan Trussell.
If you hate women and you're an ageist.
I love women.
I hate bronze league.
I don't say I love women.
You know what I say?
I love Nice women.
I don't say I love men either because a lot of men that are cunts,
a lot of men suck.
Remember we were talking about big foot.
Somebody actually killed him.
They didn't just kill one.
Oh,
you mean that game?
Spoiler that don't spoil it too.
Spoiler.
Hey,
don't spoil it.
Duncan thinks it's important.
Not Spoilers.
I'm not looking at show it to me offline.
Instead of,
Oh,
you son of a bitch.
Boy doesn't even care.
This is insubordination.
If this was any other company,
if it was not,
it was working for any other company besides the death squad as affiliated
company,
like the Freak Party.
Hey,
right here.
He gets him.
I don't give a fuck bro.
I don't want to see him shoot big foot.
Big Foot.
Probably a man.
Oh look.
So sad.
That is sad.
Well,
let's put it something happy to balance this out.
Okay.
Pull up the Godzilla trailer.
Oh Dude.
They have Oppenheimer quoting the Bhagavad Gita.
Ah,
wonderful.
Brilliant.
Find it.
You've got to find it's on daily motion.
It's on my Twitter.
If you go to my Twitter,
it's one of the most recent posts,
but it's the trailer for the new Godzilla.
No,
mother fucker does this look good.
Can't wait to see.
I got a three quarter staff just watching the first 10 seconds of the trailer.
I didn't even know.
I was just like,
oh,
they're doing it right.
They're doing it right.
It's not out.
Apparently it's a,
it's a concept and they were about,
they're building it right now,
but it's a Warner brothers.
Wait,
say a property,
check this shit out.
Sign.
Are you giving them
full attention?
Yeah.
Two
people cried.
Most people were silent.
Look at this shit.
We're looking at smashed buildings.
You could find it online.
Folks can stop the Internet.
You can't take p out of the ocean.
Hindu scripture.
Tara seven.
I don't know why they it to try to remove this for some reason like it's on
youtube sites.
It's pulled down.
You know what that is?
That's some ancient dumb ass thinking.
That's some executives that don't get [inaudible]
this motherfucker.
No,
I am becoming a destroyer of worlds.
Okay,
listen,
if that doesn't take,
get your Dick hard moved to France.
Alright,
just go get the fuck out of America.
If that doesn't get your Dick hard quit.
Meanwhile,
the Japanese invented God's will.
By the way,
this sends a parody of a,
a really racist nationalistic American comes out in 2014
the well just the attitude that they have in creating that clip.
When you taught me,
you know you got Oppenheimer talking about the Bhagavad Gita and when they,
when they Oppenheimer for folks who don't know is the guy who like was the most
critical aspect.
The Manhattan project was a huge project obviously,
but the most critical aspect was Oppenheimer and he's as being the guy
who figured out how to make a fucking atomic bomb.
Yeah,
that fucking,
that is an incredible verse,
man.
I have become death.
The destroyer of worlds.
That is so bad ass dude.
That's really cool.
Yeah,
so that's going to be,
that's going to be intense.
So big.
Bigfoot's dead and there you go.
There's a bunch of people say they saw it,
they've,
they've found bigfoot this week.
There's a new video,
a big foot,
and we won't even show it because I'm not gonna fucking salt you.
The shit is read that.
That's not the idea.
This is more,
I didn't even,
big foot.
He thinks it doesn't have to it.
He's like,
Oh shit.
Is this grand theft auto because it's got a mask.
They,
this is fucking huge spoiler dude.
Stop Brian.
That's so rude.
I hope some of the,
actually just use the grand theft auto engine to create that and that wasn't
real.
No,
this is the sleeping big foot and it's a female.
How did they know it?
Totally.
Well,
they smell this pussy pussy a mile away.
Smell like a tuna that got hit with a musket line out there in the middle of the
woods.
What do you think it sounds?
It must be a female.
A male can't smell that fishy.
What is that?
This is a piece of a big fight.
Shit that they found.
Yeah,
that's mountain line shit.
It's got l Karen it dump console.
I'll tell you right now,
I've only been hunting for a year.
I can tell you what the fuck that is.
I might be wrong by the way.
I'm very confident and what I did.
Don't mistake that for being accurate.
This is a,
well,
these people are crazy as fuck.
Todd does hotel,
who's a professor at Nyu,
who we had on that podcast.
If there's one thing that we answered on the Joe Rogan questions,
everything.
It's not within our big foot is real,
but it's whether or not the evidence that has been purported to be big foot DNA
has been acquired in the most non contaminated way.
And that answer is clearly no,
this isn't,
there's not a direct chain of command between finding this and like documenting
the fact these guys were rubber gloves.
They had masks on,
they picked this up with tweezers.
When you find human DNA,
it's amazing how easy it is for humans to get DNA on shit.
Now they can get DNA.
They,
if you sneeze,
if you breathe,
if you touch something with your sweaty skin,
you get human DNA on things.
It's incredible how sensitive these pieces of equipment are.
So when you get some fucking piece of shit that a hunter found the woods,
it was just squatch Turd squatch came by shit on my elk carcass.
You don't know what the fuck happened before that thing got to you.
And when you start testing it,
it's very irresponsible scientifically.
So whether or not these people were telling the truth,
I believe they are.
I believe they really believe that it's a big foot Turd,
whether or not,
or hair or whatever the fuck they claim they have,
or many pieces of evidence that claim they have.
The real problem is all of them have been extracted from the crime scenes
unscientifically so me as executive bros or Duncan Trussell s cohost of Joe
Rogan questions,
everything we say,
go fuck yourself.
That shit ain't real son.
That's a fucking chick with a Sasquatch costume.
I really don't think
anyone thinks it's real though.
Even the news,
when they showed it on the news,
they were like,
oh,
here we go again.
Oh,
that's not true.
I saw some dummies that were being interviewed that seemed like they really
believed in it.
That's so,
there was a few dummies.
I really think they acted like they believed in it.
I don't know the answer,
man.
That's what,
that's what I learned from this show is I just,
I have no fucking idea and I,
and,
and anytime I think I know something,
it always turns out to be something wrong.
And generally if I let myself just be in the state of not knowing if things get
a lot more interesting anyway,
I don't know if there's a big foot,
there could be a big foot anywhere.
There could be undergrad.
They could live in the earth like Hornets in a hive.
No,
it's more likely than bigfoot is that little tiny person thing.
That orange pen deck.
Sure.
That's more likely they found these motherfuckers.
14,000 years old,
Joey,
three feet tall,
hobbit dudes.
They had spears.
They might've like actually like a find them.
They found them on the island of Flores.
They're called the Homo Floresiensis IHSS or something,
something like that.
They're there.
They were the real live 14,000 years ago.
They ain't shit.
And they have legends about these little people who could fly or they rode birds
or something.
But you imagine those giant fucking get out.
How to fucking kidnap eagles.
How about this giant wasps?
Insane killing people in China.
And by the way,
this was like a week after we were talking about wasps on a podcast with Josh
Barnett.
Josh Barnett obsessed with wasps.
How crazy gangster wasps are.
And they could just fucking,
they kill everything.
They killed tarantulas.
There's videos of wasps fucking up trenches.
Cause wasps can keep stinging.
Have you ever been stung by a wasp?
They can kill you.
No,
I haven't,
but I have.
It is awful.
The ones in,
you're seeing these Chinese ones are Japanese ones.
These are giant.
Oh,
he's are enormous wasps.
They're stingers or like hypodermic needles.
Yeah.
And they're just punching holes in Chinese.
Did the size of a small mouse.
Okay.
It's a sense of a handle.
Fuck that.
Look at the size of that guy's hand or girl's hand.
Gowe should we say Gal?
That's it.
I don't to send anybody that's a last,
last young maiden.
I think it's a dude.
It looks like,
I hope.
I hope whoever they are,
they're not sensitive.
So dire.
It would be boom,
being so needy.
Oh,
can you imagine getting swarmed by one of those things?
Would they've killed 42 people and injured 160 plus in China over the past,
you know,
the past few months.
Well,
they don't know what's going on,
but these,
they're fucking huge.
I know what's going on at portals opened up to hell and those things are
climbing out of it.
The apocalypse is a slow moving event.
It's glacier like,
it's not like an asteroid.
The apocalypse.
There's no apocalypse.
Listen,
cock sucker.
You want to smell my ass?
That's the apocalypse.
I pulled my pants down.
I'll unleash that in and out.
Double double and your face.
Speaking of the fucking apocalypse,
man,
I got fucking hockey was riffed waiting in my house right now.
Don't get enough.
Don't get back.
You're sweaty,
man.
Why are you sweating?
You're not going anywhere because you're hanging out at the end of this podcast.
Where am I going?
There's people that are listening to this.
Depending on you.
Don't be so selfish.
Don't get caught up in the wave
of selfishness that is addition.
I wasn't going to abandon.
Oh,
it's not addiction.
It's going into an alternate universe.
That's not addiction.
I want to see Skyrim in three D so I'm going to shit.
Doon Doon Doon Doon Doon.
Wow.
Oh my God.
Fuck that.
Those are like puppies.
Big is a photo of a guy or a gal with four of these giant Hornets.
You really do need to know if it's like a Shaquille O'Neal size hand or if it's
like a sand.
Yeah,
small.
Let's put it on the last little Lester's hands.
Little less stressed.
Tiny.
Hi,
Arizona's still these seats
DC Trussell what happened?
What did I miss?
He putting it in you taking those babies and getting them killed by Hornets and
your game.
You can't,
there's no gain in your mind.
If you had one though.
If you had a baby that was alone in the crib,
like the mom was on math and the mom fell asleep and the game is right next to
the baby passed out,
but a window opened up in a hornet,
figured out its way through.
Would you allow all the Hornets to come in and kill the baby just so you can see
what it would be like.
This is like this.
This is like,
um,
what was that?
What was that movie with Harrison Ford total.
Not Total recall.
Blade runner.
It's like questions.
Here's the questions you ask to android to make them start malfunctioning.
That's exactly what I'm doing.
I'm trying to fit all this laying on its back.
Its legs are waving in the air at camp.
I'm trying to figure out whether the a tortoise,
what's a tour it is.
It's a turtle.
I'm trying to figure out whether the uncomfortable moments and the,
the,
the animosity that you face in your life is turned you irreversibly towards the
dark side.
I'm trying to figure out whether they can introduce you to the force.
Yours.
You are saying that if I was to let Hornets attack it digitized baby,
I would be evil.
Well that you would want to experience that will,
what about,
yeah.
If you had the options between Hornets and a slew of Bikini pageant contest,
entrance blowing the kid,
let
me tell you something man.
If you ever played fallout three,
no.
The game where you wander through the new,
the,
the apocalypse and fallout three.
Well there's a,
there's a mission and fallout three where there's a little like commune of
orphans.
You are living in some kind of cave.
One of the missions is then there's,
uh,
there is,
an,
an part of this world.
There's a,
there's like a compound of slavers so you can bring them people,
you can sell people to slavery there.
And one of the missions built into this game is you go into that fucking
compound of kids kidnap one and bring it back to the slavers to do whatever the
fuck they're going to do to the kid.
And they give you some weird special executioner's mask that gives you powers
and that's encoded into the fucking game.
So that's what's weird about video games is there's this like,
uh,
people will do awful shit and games you went to,
oh,
I wouldn't,
no,
I wouldn't do that,
but I probably,
I probably would on you.
You know,
like if I had an option,
you know,
if you could like pick who would want,
he'd,
well,
I'll give,
you could say like a public figure,
you know,
like who think of someone who really annoys you some,
I don't even don't even mention the name.
Let's just take some horrible foreign dictator type character,
some Kony,
whatever it happened to kone boy did there.
Is there a fucking cause it went away any quicker than that Kony 2012 thing.
All you got to do is whip your dick out and run around the St Pete and off and
then it doesn't matter how many babies die in Africa.
Everybody's like,
it's this fucking,
this topic is over.
He went to Oprah.
Did he?
Well,
the guy was in the middle of the fucking street beating off in San Diego.
The Guy who likes started this organization and put the whole thing together.
He see me.
You can find that video,
Brian,
whatever it's caused by.
I don't give a fuck.
It's,
there's a lot of kinds of stress in this world.
This one step of trust.
It's called fighting off the gay DCT.
What did you think when this whole thing went down?
This guy got arrested and he was beaten off the middle of street.
Does that makes sense?
Right.
Totally makes sense.
No,
I thought it was something even deeper than that,
man.
I thought it was some kind of attack from the guy in mind on him because he was
ripping people off.
I don't know if he was for sure,
but I was suspicious of him.
And so I thought that it did reach this like psychic,
uh,
some kind of psychic magnitude of negativity just swirled down on him and
temporarily exposed him to the world in this is somebody that maybe isn't
reliable or somebody that you shouldn't be sending money to.
I don't know exactly how they were using the money that they're getting,
but I know with a great many charities,
um,
legally they should
look at them.
You're totally right.
By the way,
I hate to interrupt you there,
but you're totally right.
This is him walking around naked and the old man behind him during San Diego,
it's all like ex military and shit down there.
They're like son of a bitch.
I stormed the beaches of with Gemma and you fucking cock sock or run around my
neighborhood showing you and dick to my wife.
I'll fucking kill you.
But this is something I write though.
What is that?
It's about this south park song about this.
Oh,
south park had a song about whacking it in San Diego.
By the way,
if you watch this season of South Park,
brilliant shit,
man.
You got to get back on the southpark horse going out to everybody.
God bless them.
When you're someone like South Park that has that kind of power,
the way they use it as,
so just they wield the fucking all mighty sword of,
of retribution,
of comedy,
of,
of ethics.
They're just right there,
right.
So many times I never disagree with them.
It's cut to,
I'm shitting on me.
Did you see the book of Mormon?
I loved it.
Yeah,
I saw.
I seen it.
Yeah.
It's great.
I mean,
I'm not in the musicals,
so for me to love it is,
it shows how good,
it was really fun.
Yeah.
I was,
I was way lit when I went to see it too.
It's really,
it's an,
it's a really interesting thing today.
They're so like,
they're,
they're so prolific.
They do that show every week and somehow they managed to find time to develop
not just a musical,
but a really good one.
Yeah.
And it just makes you go,
God,
I'm such a lazy bitch.
Ah,
as Duncan thinks about how much time oculus rift is going to chew out of it.
Yeah,
I,
that's the thing,
man.
You know,
I understand the lazy bitch theory,
but fuck,
like what are we supposed to be doing on this planet if not burrowing into the
imagination and digitally experience alternate realities for the,
for something that's for the first time in human history is that has happened.
It's a brand new experience.
What am I supposed to do?
Go to some fucking pool hall and bet 15 bucks.
Show ideas.
Let him know what the fuck's wrong with what he just said.
I have no idea.
No fucking idea.
Because I'm looking at him.
I know he's a brilliant dude.
So you'll go home right now and when will you be outside in the daylight?
Again,
the truth,
because I know there's times years ago you'd disappear.
Depends on it.
There's daylight in the oculus rift land that I visit.
So you sign up tonight,
you shut your phone and lock the door.
I do window in new headlines.
Young gamers finding Oculus riff makes their body produce vitamin D without the
sun.
Yes.
Exclamation point,
fingers.
It actually triggers it.
You don't need that
sunlight.
Listen you first world or as they're all stuck on your fucking son in the light,
when will you see the sun again?
When you see light
solid B,
this guy?
Yeah,
that's it was Omni Directional treadmill.
I got to get one of those.
Know it's,
fuck that guy though.
No one.
No one wants.
Fuck that guy.
Someone wants to fuck.
You'd Dunkin.
Take advantage of that.
Let's see.
What does he have on the wall?
Big Girl with giant tits that we'll never have sex with them voluntarily unless
her rent is late.
I think there might be a great many people out there who aren't being fucked at
this moment.
Why?
For sure they get to run on a treadmill and experience some magical,
weird realm.
I think they should,
but it's,
I find it shocking that the first incarnations of it involve violence and not
sex.
The first incarnations of now my friend,
yeah.
Put on Oculus Rift Porn.
Yeah.
He says that you look down and you see here today.
Well what are we looking at right here?
We're looking at violence.
This is Darrin Patriot.
Do we look in dudes with guns when they're running around?
They're hiding behind barrels and trying to snipe on people being assholes.
Yeah.
So like,
you know when you give a squeaky toy to a dog,
oh boy.
And you realize that that squeak is the sound of an animal dying.
And that's why they liked the squeak because that sounds the sounds.
I never thought about that until right now.
That's what it is.
So,
so like,
you know,
your sweet little dog's chewing on this thing,
it's squeaking just like an animal would if it were biting it.
Well that's what these games are for humans.
There's squeaked toys.
They like let humans
experience the aggressive side that exists in all people.
You know,
there's this thing where people are always shocked like to think that we're
using this for violence,
but it's like what we are.
I think it's Cathartic.
It's Cathartic,
I think.
I think it's Cathartic and it helps people,
you know,
uh,
get out aggression or just experience like,
you know,
bizarre states of being
Joe,
you don't fuck with games,
period.
You've never fucked with games except pool when you're,
when you know you were at the bar when you were young kid.
Um,
we,
uh,
I don't even know the fucking name.
It's amazing shit.
If I'm going to amaze crossword PAC man,
pac man,
dude,
if I go,
if I,
if I Miss Pacman is apparently better in Hollywood male feminist.
What they do with this machines now,
they take it all those games they put ms Pac man pac man.
Yeah.
The one with the missiles.
They didn't do the ones that you to start from scratch.
All that shit.
Pawn stars too.
I know this one stars,
they fucking sell those games,
so it's amazing.
He's has one the solid do a bar.
Oh,
they have it.
Why did I,
the guy that sent those out,
four k TVs,
he sent us one,
like a bigger arcade.
It has like 500 games on it.
Is that called name?
Is that what that is?
I think it's amazing.
Do you know that people think that I'm a fucking Nazi because of that stupid
Zombie robot?
People are so stupid.
There's so many people that are like looking to find some sort of crazy
conspiratorial connection.
Did they've,
they've decided that because it Brian Studio at the Ice House,
which by the way,
I have zero,
zero input.
How he designs it.
He just does it himself.
I'm not a control freak and uh,
Brian has a fucking Zombie that this dude.
Do you remember homeboy's name?
Yeah.
Let me find it real quick.
Um,
Dude's a,
uh,
he makes those for movies.
You know,
like that movie dead snow.
Did you see dead snow?
I don't think I saw great fucking movie.
Stupid as shit,
but great.
And it's all about zombies that were,
they were Nazis and somehow know they became zombies.
He got frozen up in the fucking south pole or some shit.
And these people are out there that camping out and then the zombies come and
get them.
The Nazi zombies.
It's hilariously stupid.
So he has one of the zombies from dead snow.
It's a fucking movie.
Okay.
He's got the Zombie at his studio and I get all these messages from people that
are saying,
yeah,
I always knew that he had a problem with Jews.
That's why he's got a Zombie at his studio that has a swastika on Joey's falling
asleep.
What?
Domo falling asleep,
falling asleep.
She only had his eyes closed.
He was like this,
I'm going to take a nap.
You wake up early
seven I like,
I'll wake up and like look on Twitter and Joe has been tweeting since 4:30 AM
can I go to bed?
We,
we change off.
We have strict,
you know,
you ever see that cartoon with as a sheep dog and the coyote and they meet.
I'm the coyote.
He's a sheep dog.
We meet Martin and Frank Ahrens.
Sam.
I was doing fine.
Three the whole day was going great and I stopped at the weed store at about
1230 1215 in the afternoon?
Yeah.
Just have a few were there last night that wasn't telling us the night before
last we were there.
No,
no.
Which night you also,
it was only tweeted the thing I went in there this afternoon.
I went to the one on Lankershim to lock up.
They have edibles and reefer.
They got a lot more selection here.
Other places has strong pocket of weed.
Right.
This one has a pre rolled joints.
Dynamite.
As we've got edibles,
a dynamind weeds is dynamite.
I going there this afternoon and it shouldn't have to get,
he goes,
hey,
I got this new thing I want you to try.
It's a fucking little Brownie thing.
It's just he goes to these people always have solid stuff.
Tell me what you think.
I took a bite out of it and I could tell it was going to be a ride.
I can tell I took a bite out of it.
Like a little bite.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
wow.
And also it's been hit me this afternoon,
but I'm more right.
These crazy hippies are so inconsistent.
This is so inconsistent with their product like you will get well,
five x cookie that's not that big a deal and then you get one that makes you
think about everything that went wrong from ages three to six.
You'll see it all
play out in front of you,
man.
I bought one of these chocolate bars and took a little bite of one tiny,
tiny,
tiny little bite and I fucking like within tasted within two hours you could
taste it.
I'm like,
it's a,
it was a,
it was when we were having the heatwave.
I'm so paranoid that I'm like,
I'm just going to go fucking jogging.
I want to go jogging and try to sweat it out.
I'm Robb,
I'm running by the La River.
Look down,
see some guy taking his pants off.
Perfect.
Suck his cock.
What it tastes like.
It tastes like river water.
God,
it's like a Brownie.
I found
the perfect dose for me.
Edible wise.
It's a la speed weeds,
gummy bears too.
Gummy bears.
Perfect,
right?
There's a little confusion when it comes to like the breast strips.
Breast chips depressives are very tricky.
I never go with a full breast trip cause you don't know what the fuck you,
you're,
it can get too scary.
But the gummy bears for some reason seem to be pretty consistent.
I think it's how they make gummy bears.
I don't know man.
Who knows?
It's illegal.
That's why we have to have this fucking conversation.
Well you've gotta be careful cause you know a lot of people they go and get
their prescription and then they go next door and buy some marijuana brownies
and they think,
oh it's just a Brownie.
I'll eat the whole Brownie and then Satan is dragging them by their
kicked my ass a little couple of minutes ago.
But that hasn't been fucking wrestling man.
I took one bite of it but I knew how it was packaged.
The whole thing.
These are real.
Yeah,
I know these people.
I'm like wow,
this is pretty fucking good.
Yeah.
Well you know what?
I think that it is important and people that hear this and go,
guys guys are talking too much shit about a weed and talking about weed,
Bro.
It really is something that people need to hear.
They really do.
Unfortunately,
the eating of the Brownie can really fucking be psychologically devastate.
Yeah.
Or chocolate bar or whatever.
Any edibles can really fuck your world.
Your world up,
Joey.
Yeah,
you gotta be careful and sometimes I tell you,
even like I learned what?
Acupuncture,
I never get high before I go to acupuncture because it turns into a complete
different realm.
I feel.
I feel every needle go into my skin.
I feel every needle break the skin.
I can hear it.
It's like having Spiderman sense.
You can hear it.
You could hear the needles hop.
If you could just feel the needle car was spot on with your skin.
Well,
I'm not high.
I don't feel that.
And when,
and that's what kills me.
That's what stresses me the fuck out.
Once I feel a little bit of pain from a needle,
it shoots up to my brain.
If I'm straight,
I'm fine.
But if I'm stoned,
it takes that little bit of pain and does something else with it.
And next,
you know,
I'm having a goddamn anxiety attack.
So that's why you gotta be careful with situations like that.
Well,
like I say about bombing,
the,
the best I've ever gotten out of standup comedy.
He was one of bombed and realized that I need to fucking make some sort of
corrections.
Those,
that's,
that's the best improvements that I've ever gotten.
If similar to the,
the feeling that you get when you eat,
you eat a Brownie or whatever and you freak the fuck out.
I've been reading this book called the Yoga Sutras of Patanjali.
Have you heard this if this book or do you have to checking g Pecan?
Julie?
No,
that's but tangent.
But they talk about how the mind ah,
how there's a term called [inaudible] and Richie's is the term for a wave of
thought.
And so like your mind is basically all these waves of thought rolling through at
rolling through it.
Each of those are of ritzy and those things are sort of uh,
um,
you are created by things in the external world or other thoughts or feelings
that come into your mind.
So when you get super high,
what's happening is you're suddenly amplifying those.
Richie's you're seeing these thought patterns that normally are way under the
surface and those thought patterns or it's usually shit you've been ignoring.
Like for me,
I'll start thinking about like,
you know,
well like when I had cancer that's,
that would come to my mind like shit,
I'm probably going to die.
I might die,
this could kill me.
Or you know,
whatever the thing is that you've been trying to ignore or forget about it just
will grab your face and push you right into it.
And so the answer is to just embrace that thing,
dissolve into it,
go into it,
fly into the f.
It's like Dante's inferno.
The only way out of hell and Dante's inferno is by going to the middle and
climbing down Satan's leg.
Cause getting Dante never tried to suck.
Satan stick.
If you suck his dick as he comes in your mouth,
your brain explodes and you appear in the garden of Eden with Eden and she
hasn't given the apple to the snake yet.
Hayden's the stripper that live in the guard whenever,
whatever her name is that the whore that was eve eve spread.
There's just some like dirty girl who lived there too.
They never done you all talk about it because all she did was just clean her
house.
She had like wet warm towels.
She had just wiped her ass after he shot the field.
She always stopped you on it and Brian stuff video.
Start putting a video on him.
You gonna change the whole tone of this fucking show,
son of a bitch shades.
Joey Diaz.
What are you doing this weekend?
Making a movie cause way too high.
I got til the eighth on this thing.
What is this thing you're doing right now?
Your,
your life has changed.
No,
I always do one of these big heavy,
yeah,
but yeah,
me yet.
I was at the fucking,
the storyteller's show the other day.
Your life is changed.
No brother.
That was a good fucking thing.
The other,
it wasn't,
it was a lot of fun.
It was a lot of harsh.
If you're a storyteller,
show a,
this is not happening on comedy central.com.
I had to leave,
I had to do Kevin and being in the morning I had to get out of there.
But uh,
the reaction that you got when you even walked in the building,
your,
your uh,
your life has changed.
Rocking your,
you're limited a different world and you were living in,
in a couple of years and you know,
I'm fine.
I'm still the same.
I know you are,
but it's interesting to watch,
man.
Interesting.
Watch what was the last Gig we did together?
Where the fuck,
where are we?
Boston.
Milwaukee.
No walking one of those.
Yeah.
Milwaukee and Boston were both in sanity.
Are you doing another,
uh,
those dog movies?
Yeah.
Which one is this one?
Easter.
How many times his dog?
Gonna fucking say that.
Cause it's a fifth one Gary time.
Pat Valentine Pass.
Or they brought you back?
No,
I always come back.
But you're saying the gallery Valentine's time passed on this one.
Wow.
Dean Cain.
This is,
he took a little pit stop before searching for bigfoot.
This is full.
It's got a new show and he's got a new shell and spike with my pal Todd.
This hotel,
they go searching for bigfoot
the girls girl's makeup.
Is that what it was?
They dress you up like a girl and you know,
why do you know why?
Cause it scared you.
Just like they do with black men.
What?
My Ada,
think about it.
All the black man,
they dress up like women.
It was the third movie we did.
Yeah.
That ever dressed me up.
Like Dave Chappelle had a whole,
a speech that he did on one of those talk shows about it.
About man,
why is it when black man gets famous,
they always try to dress them up.
A girl as true Eddie Murphy,
thinking about all the different people.
Jamie Foxx,
think about all the different people that addressed the Kenai wanes.
Thinking about all the different Tepa big,
strong black man.
And it's hilarious.
They dress up like women.
Why Joe is why they do it to you?
That was just a third because they've seen your Dick Online.
That's what it is.
They've seen the Cuban,
that girl floating out there like the death star.
Deep Space.
What's wrong with you?
You know what I'm saying?
It was stolen until the guilt Dunkin for the right.
Let me read bend to the left of me and you gotta be over here when you jumping
back into the comedy world again.
This Saturday I'll be at the comedy store.
Oh,
what type?
Cocksucker 10 40 1110 45 that's something about that place,
right?
Still to this day,
exotic.
He
sonic place.
Isn't that weird?
Fucking Hobo made his debut.
That's exactly where he made.
Who's Hobo?
Oh,
the store.
What's the new Hobo like?
I,
I've retired.
How about shut the fuck up.
Why would you do that when it's on video?
So why does everything have to be on video?
Because the other people should enjoy it too.
Well,
you developed or something that was really beautiful was real.
you know the problem there was a technical problem,
which is that it uses a pink Floyd song and I super doubt that if I email them,
they're going to be like,
yeah,
you could use are one of the most famous songs on earth for your comedy out.
Guess what?
That's a small part of that,
but very small.
It's not even one 10th of 1% of that bit.
That bit is,
I don't want to say anymore because I don't want it to be a spoiler.
You don't need that song,
Dude.
That's silly,
but I feel,
you know,
like the next time I go back out in the road,
I don't think I can bring little Hobo Joe Diaz tell him to put that fucking shit
down on wax.
I can't keep doing it though.
I can't.
You can't keep doing something then I don't have to keep doing it.
You just have to do it and get it on DVD or get it on a video to put it on the
Internet for that Little Hobo bit,
to not get out there in the world is a crime against humanity.
You need to figure that out.
Thank you.
You need to figure out how you're going to get that out.
Okay.
Cause I can't tell you how many times a fucking howled with laughter at that
bit.
I've seen that bit close to a hundred times maybe.
I mean,
all the times we work together.
I love doing it.
It's a fucking great bet,
dude.
You need to,
people need to see that.
It's fun and it's so you,
so you,
if anybody was like wondering what can I count?
Counties Dunkin do,
but he got six minutes.
Sit down and watch this.
You know what's fucking cool though,
man.
I can't get,
I can't give too much of it away,
but I am going to be puppeteering.
Uh,
I pop that.
I'm going to be using a puppet for this show we're doing for MTV digital that
we're shooting right now.
It's going to be really cool.
A lot of spooky,
spooky sketches.
Okay,
let's get into the Dunkin psyche.
Let's find out what that's all about.
Joey Diaz.
He used to always say there's a motherfucking Dunkin is always playing around
with the devil one of these days.
You gonna fucking realize that devil's is gonna bite him right in the ball sack.
They did do.
It doesn't really,
I'm off.
I don't really know.
I was just kidding.
No,
no,
no.
You know,
listen man,
there's no dark side.
You can't be fucking around with the devil.
Duncan Trussell well being cute.
All he,
he's in house watching the cartoons
get them.
My point is,
I'm just joking around about that,
but my point is like what is your fascination with this demonic idea?
You're,
you're drawn to that angle so often.
Like what,
what is it drawn to it?
To what angle drawn to the angle of,
you know,
obviously I don't believe that you think in these things like as far as being
reality,
but the idea of a demonic entity,
the idea of evil incarnate.
You've often talked about evil as like a philosophical idea,
like a location that you can get to.
You know,
man,
I've changed a lot in my life and there is a time when I actually did believe
that there was some there,
there and I still have,
I know people who do believe in this kind of thing.
But you know why you don't anymore.
What you know,
why you're doing anymore.
Why your girlfriend's 24 you think that's why I don't believe in evil anymore.
As you look looking vagina,
it's like drinking out of a spring when you've been traveling a desert,
you traveling the designee come down the hill.
And what is this?
This is this an oasis?
Is this a hallucination?
And you're getting that cold Colorado spring water and just lap it up.
24 is not old Joe.
That's not what I'm saying.
I get it.
I know it was a joke.
I think it's more of a um,
you know,
he knew what I liked.
Is that too?
Well,
I think that that's a good point.
It's not,
that is not a refuge point.
Joe Diaz.
I like to say that that is a savage.
You guys are embarrassing me.
I,
um,
but I,
I,
I like the a in Hinduism,
I liked the whole cycle of things.
I was panicking and it goes straight to the Bhagavad Gita.
That's what I
fucking him time
Congress and the Diebold voting machines.
Man,
fucking lottery ticket.
I'm gonna get that midnight moon.
Whatever the fuck that is smelling good.
A little blurbs were drinking moonshine here.
Dunkin,
I pushed one in front of you.
You're not drinking anymore.
I scared.
I'm trying to,
I'm trying to lose weight so I'm not drinking alcohol.
That's not going to help you.
Being a pussy is not going to help you lose weight.
It's the exact opposite of what's going to help you lose weight.
It fucking what's going to help you lose weight is being a savage.
And what a savage does is occasionally they have a drink because they're a
fucking man.
They do whatever they want to do and then they do squats.
Well,
what I want to do is not drink.
Listen to me.
I have kettle bells here in this building.
I can help you burn.
I'm going to help you work out after this podcast is over.
I'll show you a squat routine and you can do with a fucking 32 kilogram.
Okay,
great.
Uh,
thousands like Holt's evil.
God,
it'll hurt your mother if you drank that shit.
You're,
you're,
you're dead.
Parents will fucking kick around in their graves if you,
if you drink that shit.
Kids you grew up with in high school crashed into trees.
Fucking shit.
It's so strong.
It's ridiculous.
People you've never met.
We'll get drunk.
People you'll meet in a week.
We'll fucking pass out at work.
Does it tastes good.
It actually tastes pretty good.
It's,
it's not as strong as the runner.
You think good is anybody talking about good koolaid know about doing as good
with ice cube?
What it tastes like.
It's,
it's not that brutal.
It's interesting they did whatever this is Jamie,
what is this?
What's the name of this company as smokey old smokey.
I think it is.
Whatever.
Whoever these people are,
they're bad motherfuckers.
They know how to make some real moonshine cause I've had some scary moonshine
that hurts.
And I've had some like this is pretty
fucking smooth while letting
you know that it's fucking you up.
But,
but if you talk to somebody in Kentucky,
there would be again,
that's like the wine cooler of moon shines compared to them.
You know,
like building it in the backyard.
I don't know man.
This stuff's pretty good.
Brick Duncan and I Dunkin,
I had some stuff in North Carolina.
I remember when we ate at that slam and barbecue joint.
Yes.
Do you remember that?
Yup.
That was it.
What was it called?
Was it called?
I can't remember,
but it's fucking good if you're in Raleigh.
Hold on a second.
I need to let these mother fuckers get the props.
Raleigh Barbecue BBQ.
Um,
we,
uh,
we aid the pit.
Was it the pit?
That's exactly what it was.
I thought it was,
they gave us some moonshine,
some,
some like peach moonshine.
Oh my God.
It was good.
God Damn,
it was good.
First of all,
the barbecue there.
If you're in Raleigh,
that place is sensational.
Oh,
it's so good.
It has four stars.
If you go to like the reviews online,
but that's just because 10% of the people in the world have their fucking head
deep in their ass.
Like in if,
if,
if the world was just in pure,
that would be a five star place.
No doubt about it.
And they had this insane peach moonshine and he would drink it and you go,
whoa.
And you also like it because he knows it's illegal.
You know what?
I hate booze,
right?
I hate the taste of booze.
Yeah.
It's fucking delicious.
This is good.
That's delicious.
They know what they're doing.
Um,
real moonshine is,
uh,
over a hundred proof as high as 150 proof,
which is about 75% alcohol.
So you're drinking.
Yeah.
You're pretty much just drinking it.
Freebasing booze.
And what is this stuff should stay on the side of it and say the proof.
Yeah.
I should say right on the bottle.
Eat this and you drink this.
It'll save you all the HPV.
I don't kill all the fucking time.
You won't go on.
Michael Douglas won't be spitting fucking,
I can't remember.
Yellow buttons tomorrow.
Uh,
two two,
two,
two.
I can't read the proof.
Where's it?
Say it.
There's a sign in the front.
He goes,
I'm sorry.
Oh
yeah,
that's good too.
It says 50%
okay.
Is that a hundred proof?
Why wouldn't you say a hundred proof?
Wow.
Oh,
it does say a hundred proof and the spot.
Yeah,
it's a hundred proof.
It's not bad.
That's not bad.
It's pretty much whiskey.
90 90 proof.
So it's just a little stronger than whiskey.
That tastes delicious though.
Some ice cube.
What an ice cube,
but a little mouse and gone guys are not a big one.
The little one,
three hours to kill may be something to watch.
And a fucking casino in Vegas while you're on know Monte Cristo went on thing.
Yeah,
a Little Monte Cristo.
That's perfect.
The problem is,
is when Jamie first originally gave it to me,
I thought it,
I didn't think it was that strong,
so I was just drinking it like a drink and I almost drank like a half a bottle
of it and that's like drinking a half bottle of Jack.
Yeah.
You can find
how many guys did you fucked that night?
Just you
like
fucking podcast.
This is legal to sell.
Yeah,
that's exit.
I could go to a bar,
I can go to a bar and get this.
Yeah,
this has a barcode on it.
Wow.
Midnight Moon fucked him.
Delicious ice cubes.
As long as they have one of those fucking with things on it,
that's legit.
That means it's gone through the government taxes and all that shit.
Man,
I wonder what the fuck is going to happen to this country now that we realize
that these assholes can't communicate.
They can't get along so badly that they're shutting the government down like
they're throwing a temper tantrum and then they're not working their way through
this and they're shutting the government down.
I read this thing on Reddit that I thought was a really cool solution,
which is the adding to the constitution some way that if this happens to,
I do reelections for everyone so that we can just,
um,
we can,
we can wipe the slate.
That's a good idea.
That's in competence.
That's clear in competence.
Apparently if like all the states wanted to do that,
there's a way to do that.
There's actually a way for the states to band together so that we can do
complete reelections and get,
get,
you know,
since it's not working,
they can't do their jobs.
It's not working.
Let's get new people in there.
But then they're seen rand Paul and some other dude got taught,
got caught in a conversation with their mics on about the reactions that people
are going to have to all this.
Now what do they say?
They're just talking about hedging their bets.
So just talking about saying all the things that talking points are all the
things they were willing to compromise on with the president wasn't.
And it's really spooky stuff cause it's,
it,
it comes down to this gigantic system grinding to a halt because a bunch of
people were in an ego battle and they're playing a game of chess.
Well it's almost like the founding fathers built into the machine.
I thing that I think it's supposed to alert the population that we have to do
something more.
I think that's what that is.
I mean I just saw,
I hate saying this,
I mean,
I don't know why I hate saying it,
but I just saw Jesse Ventura on Pierce Morgan and he was giving this very like
intelligent,
cogent a description of what's happening.
And he was saying,
we,
this means that we need to have a revolution and it doesn't have to be violent,
but we do need to revolutionize the way government works because right now it's
not working.
And the reason it's not working is because,
um,
there is a,
a percentage of people who don't believe that they should have to get,
the government can impose a health insurance or that,
that that can make people buy health insurance.
I think the government has to adapt just like the porn industry did.
The porn industry came along and the Internet came along and clipped the fucking
legs out of the porn industry.
Is they're still porn available,
Brian?
Yes,
there is.
That's right.
You know,
why?
Cause they adjusted.
They did what they had to do and I think the government needs to do the same.
What the Internet does not allow the government to be the same entity.
Right.
It's too obvious where the money comes from.
We know too much about lobbyists.
We know too much about the influence of corporations.
We
know too much about Congress and now congress has been influenced to the point
where they're willing to actually Lau corporations to vote as humans and with
their money and,
and,
and have no limits on how much they can contribute to individual candidates who
will eventually serve their business needs.
Once they get into office,
it's nonsense and we know it's nonsense now because the internet,
just like we know that 3,999 for a DVD with,
you know,
insert the blank.
Tara.
Patrick does not.
You don't have to do that when you can go to youtube youporn and just,
it's free.
Just beat off online and we know that now.
So that,
that that kicked out the legs.
Yes.
Digital information ones in near in a very different way.
But it's the same thing.
The Internet has kicked off the legs of politics and politics is holding on by a
fucking claw.
They're hanging on like that kitten in that we have to hang in there.
It's getting to the point where we have to do something like [inaudible]
worse or it will happen just like the ice age eventually stopped or just like
war eventually ends.
Just like we got out of Vietnam just like the civil war ended.
Something will eventually break.
We'll get to a point where we're like,
enough.
Yeah.
Well let's just hope.
I mean,
I don't,
I,
by the way lately I've just been trying to avoid the news,
uh,
which is hard when you got,
when you're addicted to read it.
But I've been trying to avoid it completely.
But the,
um,
if what they're saying,
if it's,
if it's not just a bunch of bullshit,
if what they're saying is true,
then we could go into another recession because of this.
This could drive us into another recession.
And if that's the case,
then um,
well then that means that we have to get a new,
there needs to be a new government because there's no reason for us to go into
another recession where you know that how many of them are there and the
government.
Yeah.
How many,
how many senators?
How many congressmen?
That's a really good question.
How many is it?
I don't know the exact amount.
There's an exact amount.
What is it?
200 people.
Seven.
Yeah.
It's an how many people were on the planet or on earth and how many people are
in the United States because the shit that happens in the United States affects
the entire planet.
So it's like the fact that there's,
I don't know,
I don't know.
It's sad that I don't know the number of senators and congressmen and the need
to,
it's all nonsense.
Whatever this tiny,
tiny,
tiny number is compared to the ocean of humanity.
Uh,
the fact that they're creating an unnecessary situation,
where are we going to all theoretically suffer,
uh,
shows that,
um,
we as the people have been conditioned to believe that we're powerless and so
that that conditioning needs to go away.
And the moment it did and we organized in a nonviolent way,
then they would immediately start listening to us.
It's just that everyone gets so mad,
oh,
the government doesn't represent the people anymore.
It's like,
well,
that may be true,
but what are we doing to organize to make it so that they start listening to us
again?
We need to do that.
Um,
yeah,
and no.
I mean,
yeah.
And that little,
something's got to change and no in that really what would be optimal is if the
people that were in positions of power realize that there were fucking over the
world that would be the best.
And they just said,
hey guys,
you know,
we,
we ate some pot and we realize we're a bunch of cons.
So we're willing to like try to figure out how to figure out a way how to reward
people for the work they've already done,
but yet,
and move forward in a much more ethical way of distributing wealth.
Good luck man.
Good luck.
Cause that's socialism talk you fucking calming,
right?
These people are fucking human fossils.
Look at,
imagine taking pot with Bainer.
Imagine like,
can you imagine looking across at that guy and he's like transforming into howdy
duty in front of you.
His eyes are glowing red.
No Way,
man.
I don't know if it's possible.
It seems like these are,
uh,
earlier versions of human beings.
You whose entire operating system is,
uh,
is needed an update since the 70s.
There is no imagine if you're,
if you had an updated your iPhone since when I phones came out.
That's what these people are like with information.
But they're way worse than the iPhones.
These motherfuckers murder.
They're on a bbs board in the early nineties.
Yeah,
with a 14,
four modem.
And the shit cuts out every five minutes,
then they might want to top of the ball.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's the whole thing's fucking wrong,
man.
I really liked that.
I had Christopher Ryan on my podcast and he was talking about how in indigenous
cultures,
the people who never are allowed to become leaders or the people who indicate
that they want to be leaders,
like those are always the ones people avoid is being the leaders and the ones
who end up being leaders are the ones who know the most about certain things
like fishing or hunting.
Those people are naturally followed,
right.
They don't fucking throw makeup on and try to get in front of a try to hypnotize
a country by saying the exact same thing.
Everyone always says,
good evening.
Yeah,
my fellow American president talk that weird cadence.
Why are you talking?
What the fuck is exactly right?
We've talked about that a hundred times on this show you and if you were sitting
at home with a guy and he started talking to you like that,
you would stop him.
He'd be like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Are you trying to hypnotize me?
He imagined it.
Joey Diaz just sitting across from Obama.
Joey,
what we're doing right now.
Yeah.
Bipartisan efforts have been reached.
We have reached out to Republicans.
Yeah.
For unwilling to bargain.
Even like you're fucking killing me dog.
Yeah.
You're talking to me like that.
Oh yeah.
And also the way it give me the fuck out.
I was born,
I was North Bergen,
New Jersey,
1978 look at this picture.
Look at me.
Motherfuck I'm on a basketball team with a bunch of guineas.
One black guy and a Filipino.
Why are you talking to me like that?
It's what's happening is diffusion of,
it's gone.
You're so gone.
I'm gone.
I'm watching my boy and what?
Listen.
It'll via,
how high are you on a scale of one to a billion.
I'm like six for Joey Diaz to be this high man.
Whatever you took the fallen,
that shit must have come out of a time machine
do that.
We met in Utah,
the black hole of the bulletproof wolf that pops out a portal,
opened up a worm,
vomiting it out,
whatever you ate.
The orbs basically.
Basically the orbs.
Yeah.
Man,
I cookie to,
Jody has his house.
I've never seen you like this.
Ooh.
Smoked dope and people who won't smoke dope.
And how the people don't smoke dope worry me because the people who don't smoke
dope have just called me eight times after I told him from the glass,
they days that I was doing your podcast for them from one through whatever.
They've continually called me today.
And then the people who don't smoke,
the people who smoked dope,
they don't bug me at home.
They ain't trying to fucking call me.
What do you mean?
People who don't see that?
A friend of mine that wanted to do something Friday,
I said I'm gonna be busy from like one thought,
like five,
maybe six maybe I won't see it,
but I'll call you when I get out of there.
He's already called me three times since I've been in there.
Yeah,
you're getting mad.
No,
no I'm not.
I'm not getting mad.
I just thought I spoke to him about it and it's just weird how people don't
fucking listen.
They don't listen.
They don't care to listen.
They don't want to listen.
You know?
It just,
it's always,
you know,
so that's it.
That's what I was thinking.
That's it.
This is motherfuckers don't want to listen.
They don't want to fucking listen.
I don't last for much.
Who does want to listen,
Joey?
Nobody.
Me Neither.
I don't want to listen.
That's why we,
they're too busy with my own shit.
I'm trying to sort out my own shit.
That's right.
It doesn't need to listen to anybody.
Duncan Nelson,
you get around somebody who's listening to you.
It's the coolest thing ever.
Wow.
Hence the 24 year old girlfriend.
Mystified use string words.
I go wizard.
No,
like body.
You know I love you.
You're a savage.
You take these girls.
I love it.
We teach them.
I'm not,
I'm not getting,
I'm not teaching this and she's really super fun.
We're just joking around.
Yeah.
These are jokes is honorable because,
because you like her so much.
This is where you stopped choking.
You like halted jail.
You'll come on guy.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Like you can't even joke around about it because you actually liked her.
Sweet.
It's sweet.
It's beautiful.
You're supposed to do that.
You are,
you are.
Well,
it just shows that that,
so you really are,
you know that you're,
you know,
you really liked the check.
She's cool.
Nothing wrong in being 24 I was 24 ones by the way.
When I was 24
I was dumb as fuck.
Who wouldn't want to be friends with me?
If I was 24 and I was in this room,
you'd be like,
get that Dick had out near go Mary.
So dumb
when I can.
We didn't have the Internet.
What?
We didn't have it.
Well I,
I had rudimentary,
we,
we had rudimentary intermit Lee's,
he didn't have the real internet internet download jpegs and I take a long time.
He just hope that it would like click over the tits so you could start
masturbating.
That's what porn used to be is waiting for those wines of pixels to roll down
the screen.
Well,
you know,
I think that it took a long time for us to figure out what to do with it.
So the early Internet,
like I was on the Internet in [inaudible] 94 but I didn't learn a God damn thing
until 2003 I didn't learn anything.
It was all just talking Shit and message boards and downloading porn and
nonsense.
And then somewhere along the line that all got boring and I started learning
shit.
I think we started paying attention more things.
It was also like the three years into my pot journey.
I started with the weed around 2000 so that's when I started questioning a lot
of different things in about 2000 delving into the infinite,
deeper God for the Internet.
It's revolutionizing everything,
man.
Even like fucking taxis.
Uber,
it's amazing.
Are you fucking shitting me man?
It's the exact same price as a taxi.
Tell people what it is.
There's a,
there's a,
I'm not sponsored by them at all.
I just love him.
I just used them.
I only use them once.
It was incredible.
But there's a company called Uber.
It's an APP.
And you go onto Uber,
you click a button and within when I did it the first time there,
there's a,
it's they send like a limo to your house and it was there in two minutes.
It's the exact same price,
maybe $5 more than a taxi.
And it's incredible.
Yeah,
it's just we move,
it's great in New York City,
it's a,
it's amazing.
And it's,
and the taxi companies in La took them to court and tried to sue them so they
couldn't exist really because it's such a competition.
I just talked to the taxi driver all about this and he said there's good reasons
for it to my friend,
I not friend,
this guy I know drove for one of the Uber type things and he like,
I think it was Lyft,
he got in a car accident with three other people while he was driving.
And you would think like Lyft or this company would insure everything.
Everybody would know.
He's getting sued by everybody in the car and his insurance isn't supposed to be
covering,
you know,
when he's working.
And a lot of these people don't have the right insurances.
So when you're in an Uber or something like that,
they're not getting approved by the state.
They're not getting insured.
So they're there.
It's kind of almost illegal in some ways.
So what I would never do anything illegal,
but the taxi drivers have now all have their own apps now.
Like,
like the,
like the yellow cab APP has,
it's the exact same thing Uber has announced.
So they're actually catching up trying to do that shit still.
Even if the yellow cab APP works,
you're still in the back of a fucking taxi with Uber.
You're in like a super nice car,
bottled water in the back and it's the same PR.
The main crazy thing about it is it's some $5 more,
they can't compete.
There's no way they're going to compete with that.
Like once people start really finding out about it,
who's gonna fuck call the fucking cab?
Why?
Yeah,
why would you?
And it takes longer to get a cab.
When I,
when I did the Uber thing,
it was there in two minutes.
Like,
you know,
when you see your dog take a shit and instantaneously there's a fly on the shit
and you're like,
how is that possible?
Where did they come from?
Everywhere are,
there was so many people out there driving limos.
The number of people driving limos was pretty gigantic.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
I mean,
think about where you're at.
You're in the Los Angeles area,
the amount of airplane pickups,
airport pickups,
or what limo driving is all about,
right?
I worked for Fifth Avenue Limo and Boston and 90% of my work was uh,
airports,
airport pickups.
I pick people up,
take them to New Hampshire,
take them anywhere from Logan Airport,
all look like in a hundred miles spiral,
you know,
in any direction.
Awesome.
Yeah,
so there's always a bunch of people waiting around.
Like that's the other crazy thing about limos is those motherfuckers work insane
amount of hours.
Like it's not just a,
a crazy like regular job,
like 12 hours a day,
1617,
18 go back home,
sleep for a few hours.
They'll call you in the morning.
I worked until two o'clock in the morning.
He's mother fuckers were calling me at six asking me to come back in.
I was like,
you're fucking crazy.
And then we're like,
look,
you got debt,
you've got credit card payment problems,
you've got this,
you've got that,
we'll take care of you.
Well,
I'll tell you what,
we got a fucking bounty of work.
And they're like,
see Mikey Mikey over here.
The guy had,
he had a Boston college sticker on his Cadillac,
didn't go to college.
He just liked Boston College.
Right.
It was just the limo driver.
It was kind of a sad character,
just guide.
This was all he did was work.
And he's like,
he makes a good living.
He doesn't have to bust his ass.
You know,
he's in here 16 1718 hours a day sometimes.
And they was like,
that's how you do it.
And he gets in his car and he drives off and we're like,
like,
he's got a nice apartment.
He's got a nice Cadillac.
He's driving me while this guy was a slave.
He was a slave to veal Scallopini at the nice Italian restaurant that he could
get it anytime he wants.
He was a slave to the fact that in a nice apartment with a nice view,
we looked out his window,
he felt like a winner and he was a slave to his Cadillac with his BC sticker on
it.
And this fucking guy worked every day.
And you could do that.
The good thing was if you were in a hole,
you're in a financial hole was good.
They paid well,
you could work and you can make good living.
That guy made more than 60 grand a year driving limos.
And this was back in 1999,
99.
Even 1989.
So it was a long time ago.
I'm sorry Jerry,
I'm sorry.
No,
go ahead.
Go Uber.
And so you know,
listen,
Uber obviously is $5 more than the cab.
So what that does is that on the cuts everybody again,
yeah,
like that lowers the price.
I mean it's good for us,
but it's like,
so what's good for them too.
It's just bad.
It's bad for calves.
They're busy,
you know,
at least,
uh,
instead of,
you know,
that same ride because 85 now with a little bit probably cause 55.
That's how he ever tell you.
When I drove Jeff Beck,
I drove Jeff Beck.
Uh,
well I time I didn't,
I don't know if he was,
yeah,
he was in my van and uh,
the,
um,
the manager,
it was some,
I was picking up rock stars on a regular basis and the manager for,
um,
Annie Lennox was there too.
And we went to some hotel where we saw Annie Lennox,
but I couldn't,
I wanted to get Stevie ray Vaughan.
I was a big Stevie Ray Vaughan fan.
Steve Ray Vaughan refused limos,
would not take limos,
wrote it in cabs.
All he did was riding calves.
You have a limo waiting for Steve Ray Vaughan and be like,
hmm,
thanks.
And he's like [inaudible] he put his hand up,
get a taxi throws bag and fucking the backseat and bring his guitar in there
with them and that's it.
And he was gone.
He didn't want to ride in your Limo,
man.
He wasn't interested.
It's really kind of interesting because they had,
they had a limo for him at la or at Logan Airport in Boston and he's like,
yeah,
I'm not interested.
Yeah,
probably like the thick smell of soup farts and Cologne.
Well,
he probably could do heroin,
which more comfortable.
The back of a car.
Yeah.
Right.
I don't know if this is the time where he was doing heroin or if he was just
being authentic.
Oh,
you know,
some people just decide that like you got to,
in order to do real art like that,
like real Stevie Ray Vaughan type music.
Yeah.
You got to be down in the gutter.
You gotta be down with the people.
It's not about the gutter.
I mean,
oh,
cab drivers,
not the gutter,
but a cab drivers down.
That's a real dude.
You know,
you're driving around a city and you taking a cab and the cab is driven by guy
lives in the city.
That's a guy was working,
but he's also on the grind.
That's a real dude,
you know?
Sure.
Man.
That's one way to look at things.
But every time I get in a fucking cab,
I feel like somebody would just amaze me with your car.
I don't feel like I'm with a fucking people.
I feel like I'm in a gas chamber filled with Shitty Cologne.
Well,
Dzhokhar's.
All right
man.
If you're trying to get laid and you live,
not when it's mixed with garlic burps and the smells,
so money's rati to us.
The smell at somebodies rotting prostate,
we're there every day.
They just poured your car under their ass hole to try to cover up this rotting
stink of their intestines.
Writers on the stone.
[inaudible]
Dunkin Saturday night comedy store.
Yes.
Joe Diaz.
Where are you going to be at next week?
I'm good.
Ari Shaffir at cubs suck upon it both Friday and Saturday.
Sucks upon it and get your shit together.
That's a fucking fantastic.
Motherfuck on Thursday,
Friday and Saturday.
Don't fuck around.
Joey Diaz.
Ari Shapiro is very funny right now,
man.
He's on.
He's on point.
Yeah,
no,
we got this some point and shows a great show.
Well,
you know,
everybody's been accelerating.
It's been fun to watch.
I'm not going to say the bit,
but the bit that you and I talked about on the phone that you're doing now.
I don't want to say what it is,
but it's fucking hilarious.
I love watching everybody like hit some new levels.
Liberace bit.
It's one of the funniest bits I've seen in decades.
Right?
No shit man.
It is hard.
Hard to write and took something away,
angle on it or write something around it and you get on stage.
But you know what?
I'm getting into the 50 minute bit now I'm,
I'm starting to dig those loans sets now.
It's starting to realize that the fee is the 15 minute fuck around and sit in
town was working now just stay home and sleep.
I just go into town that night early and do Thursday night and bring the
notebook
with me and by Friday I'm fucking loose man.
It's,
it's,
it's really nice to,
is it different game?
You notice a difference game and our game,
our game is different than the 15 yeah.
Come on man.
It's and the only way to do with this to do it,
it's like anything else.
Do it.
You can talk about,
you can write,
I'm trying to write my hour.
You're not going to write it bro.
You got to get up off your ass to go out and do it.
I felt the difference in when I lived in New York too.
It's one of the reasons why I did very few sets in New York City.
I was like,
this seven minutes set.
It's just not cotton at seven 10 10 minutes.
That's not cotton.
It either like I barely got warmed up,
I barely got get barely get cranking and when you're going on the road and
you're doing these long sets,
it's the difference between doing a trailer and doing a movie.
Right?
You know the trailer,
you know you,
you develop a totally different style.
You have this like real quick,
get to the point quickly shock them early,
be nice to him,
but yeah,
I get your point across.
You did.
You do thank you.
Goodnight.
And it's a sprint.
It's a wild sprint.
You're running up a hill,
but the set,
when you're doing an hour and 10 hour and 15 hour and 30 that's a different
animal.
That's an animal.
You were establishing a mindset.
Yeah,
you got to do that all the time to do that and that's such a jarring thing when
you've been doing that and then you come back and do it.
15 minutes set,
it feels really fucking weird.
It's less jarring though than the other way.
The other way is wait brutal.
When you're going from a 15 minute set and you think you know what you're doing
and all of sudden you have to do 45 and you get 35 minutes in and you're like,
I'm done.
Like I like C's.
I got no material left.
Where are you from,
sir?
Ah,
in the fucking panic.
In your eyes.
And just thinking too,
I have any jokes I haven't done.
Is there anything I haven't done or anything I'm working on that I haven't done
rambling through their Rolodex of your stone brain desperately for some scrap of
a joke.
Well for me,
back then it was not even stoned.
It was hot.
It was totally straight,
totally straight brain.
For the first few years,
I didn't even like come up beer before I went onstage.
I didn't want to have that as a crutch.
I remember the first time I went on stage,
I was shitting my pants.
I was like,
maybe I should go get a drink.
Calmed myself down and I was like,
stupid.
If you do that,
you're going to need a drink every time we go on stage.
Right.
Just take your medicine dummy.
I remember telling myself that and I just went out 21 years old,
took my medicine,
smart boy,
luckily crazy and smart at the same time.
Crazy enough to know.
It's like a really smart kid who gets a 500 horsepower car and really shouldn't
be able to drive it.
Like you gotta be careful,
stupid.
You got to know what the fuck you're doing with this thing.
You're going to hit the gas and fly off a cliff
looking sharp with the fucking UV,
abandoned the Fedora.
Is this permanent?
I've abandoned and can I shake your head?
No,
no.
Look at this,
my friend.
Look how that's what freedom looks like.
No way man.
Oh you say no way.
No Way.
I'm never shaving fucking head man.
That's it.
I am happy that I made all the mistakes that I made.
All the mistakes that I made made me who I am today and I've made them work for
me.
But if I could change one thing,
it would be not that I would necessarily,
I like the fact that I,
I I talk about the fact that I panicked about losing my hair and so I got hair
transplants and I got stupid scar on the back of my hand.
Yeah.
But logically the one thing that makes us the least amount of sense,
I should shave my fucking head.
When I was like 21 I was,
she said,
you know what?
This ain't going to last.
I should have just went with it.
Cause this is like so comfortable.
It's so like easy to do.
It's so relaxing.
It's a non factor now.
And I know it's still a factor for you,
my friend.
Here's the thing,
man.
Here's the real factor.
You do every single thing called leaders do
and I figured it shaving my head,
I might as well go to the airport and start handing out USBs with your podcast.
Just a little Fyi,
if I ever do started called.
Yeah,
I'm not interested.
Right.
A leader?
No,
of course not.
They you're a leader.
You're a leader.
You can be lead.
Tell him what to do.
I'll let you go.
I don't give a fuck.
You can be the leader.
Sure.
This is what they
play on the documentary after suicide.
Listen,
behind that comment is a spaceship.
It is a spaceship,
but they won't take you once you cut your balls off.
So it's up to you.
You want to leave on this earth and be in perpetual hell or do you want to cut
your balls off?
Put It on the Nike is get on the fucking spaceship.
Yeah.
Why?
God Dunkin.
Why not take some Alpha brain before you do it?
Take six and do some jumping jacks.
Alpha brain fouls shave.
Um,
for us.
Uh,
what does the vanilla come on out anyway?
It's out.
Yeah,
we just,
I just got a new bottle of it.
It's vanilla with Asai,
a hemp force protein powder.
It's fucking special.
What's available?
It tastes delicious.
It's so good.
Then we nailed it.
We took a long time.
This is not a slow process.
It's been really,
first of all,
Aubrey is an amazing,
yeah,
I'm talking about a pure person guy with pure intentions and a hard working dude
and a smart guy and deserves every good thing that's happened to him.
He's just an amazing guy.
He's a really unique individual and you,
you get it from his podcast,
he get it from is he puts down these videos like he,
he's made this one video about the psychedelic experience.
Me,
he's a smart motherfucker and I,
you know,
I found no weaknesses in his fence,
like a poke at people's fences and shit and try to figure out where the
weaknesses,
he's a,
he's the real deal man.
He's a young guy too.
It's very admirable watching someone go about trying to make a business and do
it correctly and do it in this day and age with all the scrutiny of the Internet
and all the cons,
just raining down shit,
rain on your head,
just opening their ass hole above your head
is emptying their bowels of failure upon your head and every point always like
and in their defense and their defense,
if you pay attention to most of human behavior,
you're going to find people tend to gravitate towards the worst if they can get
away with it.
You know they get away with what they can get away with.
But the,
the beautiful thing about people who are true psychedelic explorer's,
and that's a fucking gross term,
but I'm going to use in any way,
even though it's been co opted,
the true psychedelic explorer's really are trying to do the right thing at all
times and they understand that you have this beautiful way of describing this
thing about acting in,
in a famine state and that it fucks people up because they act in this famine
state in the same amount of resources are available.
But you go into a panic where someone who acts in a state of community and
abundance has a much different reaction from the same amount of resources,
the same circumstances,
the same completely based on the attitude.
Well,
yeah,
and and to get that sense of abundance,
you actually have to,
it's,
you actually have to experience that there is abundance.
That's the thing.
You can't fake it.
You need to connect with what some people call the source or whatever you want
to call it,
but once you connect with that thing,
you realize that you're going to be fine.
Your body isn't going to be fine.
The planet,
as George Carlin says,
the planet's fine,
but humans are fucked.
Well,
you'll,
you go into that state,
you realize,
well,
you're not permanent,
but you realize there's a much,
much greater thing happening then you,
and once you plug into that,
it gets more difficult to get back into those ego games.
They're usually based on defending whatever you consider to be the most
important thing in your life.
Yeah,
no,
I completely agree.
Yeah.
I completely see where you're coming from.
Joey Diaz,
he had done,
you know my dog.
I'm just waiting there for some though.
I need to see an opening.
I need to see some of the feet there was telling him about Arizona stone
funding.
Galactic goes talking about North Bergen,
New Jersey in 1978.
Swinging Dick like a fucking Volvo ranchy on a trapeze wristband.
What's going on in your carpet roll?
Fucking quiet Red Bay.
You're not feeding me lines.
You're not upsetting me about Joey.
This is not red bands.
Fall the micro.
Fuck you guys.
You're not fuck to me about the fuck in the,
not that you don't get a chance to talk on this podcast.
Oh right.
I'm over here waiting for something to drop knowledge,
but nobody's giving me a fucking lob.
That's nonsense.
I'll even throw me a fastball.
They just draw me curves.
Who has the biggest dick in your high school basketball team?
Can you show that picture by the way?
You do know,
you were telling me about that.
Jodie has has,
uh,
this slide podcast he does once a month.
And I was on his last one and it was probably one of the funniest,
one of the most fun times I've ever had a good line.
You only do it once a month.
Now the live ones,
if I'm busy,
I can't do Saturdays and one I want.
I switched up last,
uh,
the end of September into the Saturday night or Friday.
Man,
it was great.
We had a fucking blast.
It really was a blast.
Really was a blast because a lot of people work during the week.
Right,
right,
right.
We can't give him sobbing,
trying to work it out,
but this month I got busy.
I can only do a Wednesday,
but I'll try and November to do a Saturday night or something.
Yeah.
I think those,
uh,
there are different dynamic,
you know,
I don't think it's the best way to do all of them,
but it's fun to do some of them some way really is to see what you draw from the
audience and that spot is a great spot to do it.
And you get blase.
It's dark and you go up there and it's the perfect place and time to be funny.
Yeah.
It's like going to where they shot gladiator.
You got to fucking kill some more the fuck.
And they throw you in that stage.
Correct.
Policy on same thing at the ice house in that little stage two.
Yeah.
Energy is so against you.
Remember you have people to the left to you,
people to the right of you and people in fucking in front of you,
which is very rare.
You have people taking your corners away,
but not that wall.
You can't bond that.
There's no way to run.
You know what I'm saying?
There's no way.
It's just,
and it's perfect.
So you're up there and you're fucking,
it's like that little cheat of yet.
Right.
That little stage was perfect.
Even though you have people made you,
sometimes that type of shit is good.
You're forced to be real and they innervate environment like that.
You only get five rows.
Like Cheetahs was like five,
six rows and it couldn't have been better.
Like those,
you know,
that story that I told that was the best average told an ever and part of it is
because the energy of the other general same thing of the Ice House with that
now to do a podcast and the theater,
that's not for me,
I don't think.
I think it would turn it into a game show host condition.
Duncan,
look,
someone send you a tweet.
It says looking at the inevitable look beautiful.
What does it look beautiful?
It's Dunkin Bob.
That's really good.
I'm going to read.
I'll retweet it Brian.
And uh,
we went to prison tomorrow.
You come on in 10 years,
that's what you look like.
Nobody would recommend.
Okay.
I just retweeted it.
Don't get shot.
Hold on online bro.
You look sexy as fuck.
Like yeah,
I had a fucking swastika the forehead and
go towards evil.
Fucking come on.
Right.
And what about all the Jews out there?
They get it.
The there were fans.
Is Your bitches talking about Manson?
Big Time.
Sorry.
Good.
That's sexy.
That doesn't look that bad.
That it looks beautiful.
Dunkin.
And I'm telling you,
yeah,
that looks better than me.
Look,
right?
Han did not accurately depict my hydrocephalic head.
That's a nice
shape and you don't even know what you're talking about.
I have a fucking smiley scar in the back of my head.
It doesn't matter.
It's the ultimate test of your ego.
Your Ego is trying to convince you that you look better with hair.
You do not.
You look different with hair,
but okay,
that's great then,
but I want to,
you don't look different.
Why is there a compulsion and all cult leaders to have people shave their head?
This is something that really should submit because you can't make a fucking
weird cause you can't make him shave their Sol.
That's what nobody else is like.
You got to shave your head.
No one I know is like your head.
It'll free you there on the stove.
You can file Duncan Trussell on Twitter.
That's d u n c a n t r U.
S.
E.
L.
Duncan Trussell in the motherfucking house.
Don't bother following him on Facebook cause most of those people aren't even
really Dunkin.
You're talking to some strange girl.
Some girl pretended to be done and it was love at Dunkin.
Joey does fucking plenty of imposter Duncan's,
they're sprouting up as we speak.
How dare you lie to those people out there and not prepare them for the
inevitable.
Joey motherfucking Diaz,
he can't get them on Twitter as Joey Diaz mad flavor cause he is mad flavor.
He is.
He is the only semi white dude who's allowed to have a non deplore and we is
that I say it.
That's right.
Yeah.
Thank you.
It's a pseudonym.
Ladies and gentlemen.
God flavor.
Fucking next week.
Mad Flavor.
COBB's flying Jew.
Ari Shaffir one of the best shows you're going to see period anywhere tells up
there this week.
Oh,
Gina.
Christina peers.
Dan Sunday.
Tommy girl.
Sunday night,
Wednesday.
Oh we do it.
Oh,
opening up doors.
Promar ready?
Oh bring the reefer THC.
The Santana alms.
I don't give off.
What common in hot brings it.
I said fuck it.
This weekend I'm at the Ontario Improv with the one and only time he
motherfucking Segora Aka Tommy Ak high and tight bond.
He's there Friday and Saturday and then on Sunday it's the wonderful and
luscious Tony Hinchcliffe,
Tony Hinchcliffe on Sunday.
Perhaps Joey Diaz will be stopping by this weekend.
Bootcamp full.
You can't promise anything.
He May.
He may not.
He may naps.
He may eat two cookies and go no,
that's the best.
And come back with new information in a physical form.
You know us Brian Band,
what's up with you?
You've got a Friday night at the ice house tonight.
No,
I'm going to be an la pod fest tonight with Mark Marin and Doug Benson doing a
live show,
October 31st death squads at American comedy for Halloween 20 Hence Cliffs,
Sam Aaa,
and a lot of surprise guests.
Oh,
Shittin November 20th San Francisco Punch line.
Oh Shit.
San Francisco Punch line.
By the way,
one of the 10 greatest clubs in the history of comedy,
one of the 10 greatest San Francisco Punch line.
It's right up there with me.
It's right up there with the comedy store or the comedy works in Denver right up
there with the comedy store in Hollywood.
Those perfectly designed clubs,
punchline San Francisco stuff,
fucking bee's knees,
Dunkin piece,
and you think to add,
this is a beautiful 10th or 400th podcast whenever it was.
We love you.
That's it.
I fucking love these motherfuckers.
I love these people.
The moonshot.
It was,
can you appreciate all the,
this is going on?
Does it seem like,
to me it seems craziness.
It seems like it doesn't even make sense.
None of it makes sense.
Just too many people.
There's too many.
It's too,
too nutty.
I don't want to think about it.
We just did Toronto.
We have Toronto,
me,
Cowan and Thomas Gora.
My 80 being the fucking craziest weekend we've ever had that.
It was madness when when Brian Cowen went onstage stage said to open up the
show,
the fucking risk.
I really wish I filmed it.
I fucked up and didn't film it.
They went ape shit and I mean they went fucking ape shit.
They went crazy and then secure came out.
They went crazy.
Toronto was amazing.
It was amazing.
It's like it's,
it's hard to quantify how fucking good it was.
Toronto is such a cool city.
It's about as cool as it gets.
But there's the,
this thing that we're doing right now,
this podcast,
this is changed my life and I know it's changed your life and that's,
no,
I know.
It's changed all of our lives and some crazy buddy.
We found a hole.
We found a whole pulling people through.
Come on through.
Fucks.
All right.
We love the shit out of you guys.
And uh,
we will see you next week.
We got a lot of people coming up.
Um,
uh,
I'm in negotiations or no,
not negotiations conversations.
Sam Harris,
Maynard Keenan,
Neil degrasse Tyson.
We've got a lot of coming up.
Greg Proops is coming up.
We got,
um,
uh,
Graham Hancock is coming back.
Oh,
just get Dr German.
we'd love to get a doctor drew a David Wilcox.
We got a lot of people coming up,
a lot of,
uh,
interesting ones into November.
Um,
I booked a bunch of,
a bunch of cool people in November as well.
Um,
so,
uh,
Dave Asprey's coming back.
We've got a lot of people coming back.
All right.
Thank you everybody for allowing us to get to this crazy number of 400.
We love the fuck out of people.
We can't believe that this has gotten to where it is.
We never saw it coming.
Brian and I started almost 400,
400 shows ago for almost four years ago.
Um,
just hanging out in my house with a laptop.
Snowflakes.
Yeah.
Spinning Apple Logo.
And uh,
here we are having a good time together,
still growing and we grow from you too.
We appreciate the fuck are you guys and believe me,
it's no small thing that we,
we,
we have a great sense of,
of uh,
w w w w we owe you guys.
I mean,
that's how I feel and we have a great sense of,
uh,
attachment.
There's,
this is not just a one way street and we want you to know that we appreciate the
fuck are you guys is a massive amount of appreciation from Joey,
from Ari,
from Brian,
from Dunkin,
from all of us.
We love the fuck out of here.
People from everybody,
Tate and Eddie Bravo feels the same.
We all feel the same.
And a thank you to our sponsors as well.
All of them,
including the one that sponsored this show.
Legal Zoom used to code named Rogan Legal zoom.com and save yourself some money.
squarespace.com use the code word j Ari to get yourself $110 awesome bonus
situation type activity and uh,
[inaudible] dot com use the code name brogue and save 10% off any [inaudible].
All right.
We love the fuck out of you guys.
Big Kiss.
Yeah.